Hallo und herzlich willkommen zu Forschergeist, dem Podcast des Stifterverbands für die deutsche Wissenschaft. Mein Name ist Tim Pritlove und ich begrüße alle hier zu unserer Gesprächsserie über Wissenschaft, wissenschaftliche Themen und auch wissenschaftliche Personen, ein Feld, was wir neulich in der 26. Ausgabe das erste Mal konkret ins Auge gefasst haben, als wir über Gottfried Wilhelm Leibnitz gesprochen haben. Über seinen Beitrag zur Wissenschaft und Wissenschaftsgeschichte. Und einen ähnlichen Diskurs möchten wir heute führen, und zwar konkret einen Blick wagen auf den Physiker Werner Heisenberg. Und um darüber alles zu erfahren, begrüße ich zunächst einmal meinen Gesprächspartner, Ernst Peter Fischer.
Guten Tag Herr Pritlove.
Schönen guten Tag. Herzlich willkommen bei Forschergeist. Herr Fischer, Sie sind ja auch Wissenschaftler.
Ja das war das einzige, was ich werden wollte. Ich habe Physik studiert und dabei große Faszination für Mechanik, Elektrodynamik bekommen und wollte eigentlich auf diesem Sektor bleiben. Bin dann in die Biophysik gegangen, habe bei einem Nobelpreisträger, Max Delbrück, in Pasadena promovieren können. Bin dann zurück gegangen nach Deutschland und hatte die Hoffnung, dann irgendwann mich mal zu habilitieren und dann die übliche Karriereleiter zu erklettern. Und dann passierte es eben, dass Max Delbrück starb. Aber bevor er starb hat er mich noch gebeten, seine Biografie zu schreiben, was ich dann getan habe und seitdem bin ich Wissenschaftshistoriker. Dabei fiel mir auf, dass ich während meines Studiums schon immer großes Interesse an Wissenschaftsgeschichte hatte, nur das auf der Nebenseite betrieben hatte, weil man ja doch mit seinen Forschungsfragen beschäftigt war. Und am meisten imponiert in meiner Studentenzeit, also die fängt Ende der 60er Jahre an bis Mitte der 70er Jahre oder bis Anfang der 70er Jahre, am meisten imponiert hat mir die 1969 erschienene Autobiografie von Werner Heisenberg, Der Teil und das Ganze.
Ich habe dieses Buch verschlungen. Ich habe diesen Mann beneidet. Ich habe mich gefragt, ob ich jemals irgendeinen solchen klugen, guten, wegweisenden Gedanken haben könnte, wie dieser Mann. Ich habe bewundert, dass er Klavier spielt. Ich habe bewundert, was er alles für andere Ideen hatte. Heisenberg war ich völlig verfallen in dem Moment. Aber das ist natürlich keine Garantie, dass man eine gute Biografie über ihn schreibt. Aber dann zunächst mal habe ich ja damit auch nicht angefangen. Ich habe die Biografie von Max Delbrück geschrieben. Habe mich weiter in wissenschaftshistorische Themen eingearbeitet und dann rückte so allmählich das Jahr 2001 heran, in dem Werner Heisenberg seinen 100. Geburtstag hätte feiern können. Und daraufhin habe ich einen Verlag gefragt, ob man eigentlich eine Biografie von Heisenberg schreiben könne. Das wurde akzeptiert und dann ist das entstanden. Es ist im Pieper-Verlag in München erschienen, die auch seit Mitte der 80er Jahre die gesammelten Schriften von Heisenberg herausgegeben haben.
Und zwar den allgemeinverständlichen Teil. Also die allgemeinverständlichen Schriften und die habe ich da komplett stehen. Das sind so mehrere tausend Seiten. Und ich finde jeden Aufsatz dadrin wunderbar fantastisch. Und ich verstehe nicht, dass das keine Lektüre für Schulen ist. Also wenn einer erklären kann, wie die Wissenschaft heute philosophisch vorgehen kann, um ein Weltbild zu erzeugen, das sich lohnt, dann sind das die allgemeinen Texte von Heisenberg, die ein ungeheures Spektrum ausdehnen. Ich sage Ihnen nur ein Beispiel, in einem Fall erzählt er von Johann Wolfgang Goethe, das ist sowieso für Heisenberg ein großes Vorbild. Er nennt ihn immer den großen Menschen. Und Goethe hat ja, wie alle auf der Schule noch gelernt haben, in Neapel nach einer Urpflanze gesucht. Er meint, sie auch gefunden zu haben. Das ist eigentlich für Schüler ein eher langweiliges Thema. Was interessiert mich einen Urpflanze?
Nur was macht Heisenberg dadraus? Heisenberg überlegt sich, ob man die Urpflanze heute sehen könnte und seine Antwort ist, das ist die Doppelhelix. Die Doppelhelix aus DNA, die sozusagen dem Grund des Lebens gibt. Wo man sehen kann, wie aus eins zwei wird und Heisenberg meint, Goethe würde das heute als Urpflanze identifizieren. Und wenn Sie so etwas lesen, dann sind Sie doch an der spannenden Stelle der Diskurs, was Wissenschaft bedeutet, für das was man Weltverständnis nennt.
Ich merke schon, die Begeisterung für Werner Heisenberg sitzt tief. Aber wie Sie ja auch ursprünglich schon gesagt haben, die Begeisterung für Wissenschaft, was würden Sie denn sagen, was war denn so in Ihrem Leben eigentlich so der Auslöser, dass Sie sich so mit der Wissenschaft verkettet haben?
Ich war 15 Jahre alt, als mich ein Lehrer mehr oder weniger gezwungen hat, in eine Buchhandlung zu gehen. Ich komme aus einer Familie, wo man zu Hause keine Bücher hatte, wir hatten nur das Telefonbuch und einen Briefratgeber und sonst wusste ich nicht, dass man Bücher hatte. Wir hatten einen Radioapparat, aber das war dann auch alles. Und ich kriegte montags immer die Kicker-Zeitung, so dass ich über den Fußball informiert war. Und da war ein Deutschlehrer, der sagte, das geht so nicht weiter, damit kann man nicht Abitur machen. Ich müsste mir ein anständiges Buch kaufen. Der war sehr engagiert und hat alle aus unserer Klasse mal mitgenommen zum Spaziergang durch die Innenstadt. Und dann hat er mich in eine Buchhandlung geschleppt. Das war 1962, da war ich 15 Jahre alt. Und damals sind die ersten Taschenbücher erschienen. Und die ersten Taschenbücher, das war so Ullstein-Taschenbücher, Rororo DTV und die standen auf so einem Regal, wenn man reinkam in der Buchhandlung rechts und da waren auch die Neuerscheinungen.
Und da hat der Lehrer gesagt, das sind Bücher, die könnten wir uns erlauben, das können wir bezahlen. Und dann habe ich in dieses Regal reingegriffen und das ist jetzt manchmal das Anfängerglück oder wie Sie das nennen wollen, das erste Buch, was ich da rausziehe, war von einem mir damals völlig unbekannten Autor namens Albert Einstein und das Buch hieß „Mein Weltbild“, das war gerade erschienen bei Ulstern. Ich habe das Buch heute noch. Ich schlage das Buch auf, Anfängerglück Teil zwei und da steht, „Töten im Krieg ist Mord“. Und da habe ich gedacht, das ist gut, das nehme ich, das mache ich. Und dann habe ich das Buch weiter gelesen und natürlich wenig verstanden. Einstein redet von physikalischen Theorien, von der Bedeutung der Mathematik zur Beschreibung der Wirklichkeit. Das ging über den Kopf eines 15 Jährigen. Aber dann habe ich mir folgendes gedacht, wenn ich jetzt zu meinem Physiklehrer gehe und sage ihm, ich habe Albert Einstein gelesen, dann wird der mir eine gute Note geben, nur weil ich Interesse zeige. Bin dann zu dem Physiklehrer gegangen und kriegte eine ganz komische Reaktion.
Ich habe ihn nämlich gefragt, was die Relativitätstheorie eigentlich aussage. Und da hat er gesagt, ich solle morgen wiederkommen. Und dann hat er mir am nächsten Tag in einem separaten Zimmer die Tafel vorgeschrieben voller Formeln, die wir heute als Lorentz-Transformation Identifizieren würden und da hatte ich als Schüler zum ersten Mal das Gefühl, dass ich von einem Lehrer betrogen würde. Der hätte ja einfach sagen können, ich verstehe das nicht, aber lies mal weiter. Aber er hat das nicht gesagt, er hat einfach so geschwafelt und dann bin ich zu meinem Deutschlehrer wieder hingegangen. Der hat gesagt, das sei schwierig, das müsste man studieren. Das habe ich dann getan. Und so bin ich dann in die Physik gekommen. Ich fand Physik ungeheuer spannend. Also die Sicht der Physik, die Idee der Symmetrie, die darin vorkommt, die Vereinheitlichung dieser Theorien. Also ich konnte mich begeistern für Maxwell-Gleichungen, für die Relativitätstheorie und natürlich die Quanten-Theorie und habe mich immer gewundert, wie Menschen auf so etwas kommen konnten.
Und dann plötzlich hatte ich ja wie geschildert die Gelegenheit, Biografien zu schreiben und jetzt konnte ich das anfangen zu verstehen. Das interessiert mich plötzlich viel mehr. Wie kommen Leute auf solche Ideen und wie kommen die Leute auf diese Themen und man hatte ja jetzt plötzlich den Nobelpreisträger Delbrück, bei dem ich promoviert hatte, vor Augen. Ich hatte Werner Heisenberg vor Augen und dann wird man selbst unheimlich klein mit Hut. Und dann denke ich, dann lass doch die Physik sein und mach Wissenschaftsgeschichte. Da gibt es so viel was du tun kannst und dann habe ich angefangen, darüber zu schreiben und das tue ich noch bis heute.
Also Sie sind sozusagen Historiker aus Passion?
Ich bin jetzt Historiker aus Passion. Ich bin auch grundsätzlich der Meinung, das ist aber eine Sache, die man ausführlicher erläutern müsste, dass die beste Weise, etwas zu verstehen, die historische ist. Also wenn Sie mir erklären wollen, wie die Relativitätstheorie, jetzt schlage ich nicht vor, dass Sie mir das Gebäude erklären, sondern den Weg, den Einstein gegangen ist, um zu dem Gebäude zu kommen. Wenn Sie die Quanten-Theorie verstehen wollen schlage ich vor, dass Sie nicht sagen, was Heisenberg zum Schluss gefunden ha oder was da andere daraus gemacht haben, sondern ich schlage vor, dass Sie den Weg beschreiben, wie das angefangen hat, um zu diesem Punkt zu kommen, an dem dann Heisenberg angekommen ist. Und ich glaube, also erstens ist das für mich selbst der einzige Weg zum Verstehen. Das Wort Verstehen ist natürlich schwierig, wer versteht schon die Quantenmechanik. Es gibt diesen schönen Satz von Niels Bohr zur Quantenmechanik, wer die Quantenmechanik verstanden hat und dabei nicht verrückt wird, hat sie nicht verstanden. Also wenn Sie jetzt davon ausgehen, dass ich nicht verrückt bin, habe ich es nicht verstanden und müssen Sie mal gucken.
Und es gibt viele Leute, also auch der große Physiker Richard Feynman, der hat gesagt, die Quantentheorie kann man nicht verstehen. Also man kann das nur berechnen, man kann das nur beherrschen, man kann sich darüber freuen und staunen, aber es muss ja jemand sie geschaffen haben. Und der sie geschaffen hat ist Werner Heisenberg. Und diesen Schritt hat er uns zum Glück sehr genau und ausführlich geschildert, und zwar in seiner Autobiografie, der Teil und das Ganze. Und was ich nicht verstehe ist, dass sich nicht sämtliche Kreativitätsforscher, sämtliche Leute, die meinen, die Wissenschaft braucht so eine psychologische Erläuterung, auf diese Passage stürzen. Es gibt keine großartigere kreative Erscheinung oder kein großartigeres kreatives Moment, als diese Nacht auf Helgoland, in der Heisenberg den Durchbruch, wie man das so militärisch nennt, zur neuen Quantenphysik findet, mit dem das Weltbild verändert worden ist und die ganze Welt verändert worden ist.
Na dann finden wir doch mal diesen historischen Weg, es ist ein Ansatz, den ich sehr wohl teile, Dinge lassen sich eigentlich immer nur verstehen, wenn man die Geschichte davor auch mitbekommen hat. Und wir blicken ja jetzt auf eine Zeit, Heisenberg ist 1901 geboren, Sie hatten es ja schon erwähnt, in der die Welt ja vor nennenswerten Umbrüchen stand, was jetzt die wissenschaftlichen Erkenntnisse betrifft. Albert Einstein, ist natürlich auch hier schon gefallen der Name, maßgeblich daran beteiligt gewesen, das bis dahin geltende Weltbild erheblich einzureißen nicht so sehr, aber zumindest zu erweitern, sozusagen den Blick auch ins All zu eröffnen, indem er quasi die Erkenntnisse von Newton auf eine ganz neue Ebene gestellt hat durch die allgemeine Relativitätstheorie und damit irgendwie die ganzen Massen und Energien und natürlich am Ende auch vor allem die Schwerkraft sozusagen neu definiert hat und das ja auf eine Art und Weise, wie sie sich heute auch noch 100 Jahre später immer wieder aufs Neue beweist.
Aber er war ja nicht alleine, sondern es ist ja eine Vielzahl von grandiosen Wissenschaftlern eigentlich in dieser Phase hervorgekommen, die jeder einzelne wahrscheinlich hier auch eine eigene Sendung verdient hätte. Und jetzt kommt Heisenberg, 10-15 Jahre jünger als Einstein, 12 Jahre sind es glaube ich genau. Wann ist denn sozusagen das erste Mal ein Blick von Heisenberg auf die Welt belegt? Das ist ja dann um den ersten Weltkrieg herum?
Also der erste Weltkrieg, da war er noch ziemlich jung der Heisenberg, aber es gibt so Aufzeichnungen, Tagebücher, da scheint er über solche Sachen nachzudenken, aber nicht wirklich, dass er die Frage des Atombaus studiert. Aber angefangen mit diesen Fragen, die ihn interessierten, was die Frage nach der Stabilität und dem Aufbau der Atome anging, das ist etwas so ab 1919/20, da kam er auch zum Studium. Er hat natürlich privat nicht über das Atom nachgedacht, aber über das, was die Welt im Innersten zusammenhält, denn er war ein großer Goethe-Anhänger, er hat Goethes Faust sicher zum großen Teil auswendig gelernt und gekonnt. Und da ist ja die berühmte Frage am Anfang, dass ich erkenne, was die Welt im Innersten zusammenhält. Wobei immer daran zu erinnern ist, dass der Faust, um das herauszufinden, sich mit dem Teufel verbündet. Also Magie versucht anzustreben. Und ich bin sicher, dass Heisenberg das genau gewusst hat.
Er wusste, er muss irgendwas diabolisches magisches machen, um dahin zu kommen, aber er traute sich das zu.
Des Pudels Kern finden.
Des Pudels Kern finden und er hatte natürlich vorher eine Menge Philosophier gelesen. Es gab natürlich in der Antike Texte, die darüber nachgedacht haben, was die Welt im Innersten zusammenhält, also was da die elementaren Einheiten sind. Also bei Platon hat er viel nachgelesen, der dann von Urkörpern gesprochen hat, der von Symmetrien gesprochen hat. Also heute ist ja die komische Antwort darauf, was die Welt im Innersten zusammenhält, ist ein Quark-Gluon-Plasma. Und wenn Sie jetzt die Frage stellen, was ein Quark-Gluon-Plasma ist, dann heißt die Antwort, das ist die Lösung einer Gleichung, die ein Quark-Gluon-Plasma beschreibt. Sie können also mit anderen Worten sagen, wir sind genau da, wo Platon hin wollte, nämlich am Anfang seiner Idee. Nämlich die Lösung dieser Gleichung und nicht irgendwas materielles. Aber Heisenberg hat sich schon darüber gewundert, also als Leser von philosophischen Texten, übrigens im Original in der griechischen Originalsprache und nicht die komischen Übersetzungen von Schleiermacher, die damals zirkulierten, ich weiß nicht, ob Sie die jemals gelesen haben.
So ein ganz mühevolles Deutsch des 19. Jahrhunderts, da wird einem Platon eher verleidet. Aber Heisenberg hat das Original gelesen und hat gewusst, da ist eine große Frage, die man sich stellen kann.
Das heißt er hat erst mal Altgriechisch gelernt?
Ich muss jetzt einfach mal meiner Bewunderung für Heisenberg hier Raum geben. Der hat einfach alles gelernt und gekonnt. Der hat Geschichte gelernt und gekonnt. Der hat alte Sprachen gelernt und gekonnt. Der hat Musik gelernt und gekonnt. Heisenberg war für mich so ein Wunder, der hat dann die Klavierkonzerte von Beethoven gespielt, Platon im Original gelesen und Goethes west-östlichen Divan auswendig gelernt. So nebenbei.
Ja in München hat er studiert oder?
Heisenberg hat in München studiert, und zwar bei Arnold Sommerfeld und das ist jetzt eine ganz wichtige Figur. Arnold Sommerfeld wurde von manchen Leuten so als Grenadier bezeichnet, weil er einen so etwas starken Schnurrbart hatte, offenbar ein Mensch der Kaiserzeit ist. Aber der war sehr offen für große Ideen und hatte seinen Schülern immer sehr viel zugemutet und Heisenberg und Wolfgang Pauli, der sozusagen kongeniale Partner von Heisenberg, die waren Studenten bei Pauli und Sommerfeld hat sofort gesehen, dass diese Leute genialer, größer sind als er und hat sie deshalb auch gefördert. Und das muss man erst mal schaffen. Also sozusagen Professor sein, ein großes Problem vor sich haben und nicht hoffen, dass man das selbst löst, sondern hoffen, dass die Studenten, die man hat, einem den Weg weisen, das zu lösen und das waren eben Heisenberg und Pauli. Die er auf jede erdenkliche Weise gefördert hat.
Und denen er auch unheimliche Aufgaben gestellt hat, um sich da zu beweisen. Und dann hat Sommerfeld in Briefen gesagt, mein Gott ich habe da einen Studenten im ersten Semester, der hat da eine ganz komische Lösung vorgeschlagen, das scheint alles zu stimmen, aber irgendwie ist der doch viel zu  jung dafür. Aber das war bei Heisenberg eben so. Der kam rein, guckte und machte einen genialen Lösungsvorschlag. Das kreative Genie, der konnte jeden Tag so unentwegt Vorschläge aus dem Ärmel schütteln, die nicht immer alle stimmten, die immer korrigiert werden mussten und das Korrektiv war Wolfgang Pauli, der sozusagen gerne als der große Kritiker, als der kritische Geist gesehen wurde, der immer erstmal gesagt hat, kannst du das überhaupt nachweisen, kannst du das überhaupt zeigen? Und der die ganze Lebendigkeit und Lebensfreude von Heisenberg nicht teilte. Heisenberg war ja jemand, der ging gerne in die Wälder und wanderte und kam dann …
Pfadfinder.
Pfadfinder und kam dann morgens früh mit dem ersten Zug aus den bayrischen Bergen ins Institut und Pauli ging um diese Zeit ins Bett. Der hatte die Nacht in irgendeiner Bar verbracht und dabei versucht zu rechnen. Also das war schon sozusagen Tag und Nacht oder das kreative Genie und der kritische Teufel, die da zusammen.
Das ergibt sich ja manchmal ganz gut.
Pauli hat auch immer gern drauf hingewiesen, dass das Wort Zweifel mit dem Teufel zusammenhängt und der Teufel eben dazu gehört, um das Kreative rauszubringen und der hat dem Heisenberg schon manches korrigiert, aber hat ihm auch die entscheidenden Ideen gegeben, oder mindestens eine oder zwei entscheidende Ideen gegeben, nur dass dann Pauli mit der Idee zufrieden war und Heisenberg sie ausgearbeitet hat, denn das ist natürlich eine extra Geschichte. Ich kann Ihnen ja die Idee geben, dass es Atome gibt. Herzlichen Glückwunsch, das wissen Sie jetzt und jetzt kriegen Sie mal raus, wie die aussehen. Und das ist eine ganz andere Aufgabe. Also jetzt laufen Sie rum und sagen, hi ich weiß, dass es Atome gibt, hat man schon in der Antike gewusst, aber die haben noch nicht gewusst wie groß die sind. Ich versuche jetzt mal herauszukriegen, wie groß die sind. Und jetzt wird es schwierig. Und das hat Heisenberg gewusst. Aber er hat auch gewusst, dass er das sozusagen konnte, das rauszukriegen.
An dieser Stelle, und das werden wir glaube ich noch häufiger machen, müssen wir auch ein bisschen einziehen die Sichtweise, was wusste denn die Welt  zu diesem Zeitpunkt, als er sich quasi mit diesen Fragen beschäftigt hat. Atom okay der Name, der war schon lange im Raum, aber was es wirklich ist und ob es wirklich so unteilbar ist, wie der Name das ja eigentlich sagt, das war zu dem Zeitpunkt ja noch gar nicht klar?
Ja doch, als Heisenberg anfing zu studieren war klar, dass das Atom nicht unteilbar war. Es bestand aus Teilen und das erste Teilchen des Atoms, das man gefunden hatte, ist das Elektron. Das hatte man schon im 19. Jahrhundert entdeckt, nur hatte man keine Ahnung, wie das mit dem Rest zusammenhängen würde und dann hat man sich die Vorstellung gemacht, das Elektron ist ja negativ geladen, dass es mit einem positiv geladenen anderen Teilchen zusammenhängen muss und man stelle sich so eine Art Teig vor, wie so einen Rosinenkuchenteig, also die negativen Elektronen waren wie Rosinen in einem positiv geladenen Teig, aber das klappte vorne und hinten nicht. Nun ist folgendes ja ganz wichtig zu wissen, in dem Jahr 1900 hat der große Physiker Max Planck einen Vorschlag gemacht, die Energie, die gewandelt werden muss, wenn sozusagen die Wärme, die man einem Körper gibt, in das Licht verwandelt wird, das er ausstrahlt, dass diese Energie nicht beliebig verfügbar ist, sondern dass die sozusagen in kleinen Päckchen kommt.
Das ist die Quantisierungsidee. Max Planck hat eingeführt, dass es so was wie ein Quantum der Wirkung in der Welt gibt, und die Energie des Lichtes, das aus einem schwarzen Körper kommt, den man erwärmt hat, kann nur über solche Quantenzustände erfasst werden und das war 1900, aber da hat zunächst mal niemand drauf reagiert. Bis 1905 ist mit dieser Idee gar nichts angefangen worden.
Das war ja Plancks großartige Arbeit, nachdem ihm sein Lehrer eigentlich erzählt hat, dass schon eigentlich alles erfunden ist, man müsste sich jetzt mit gar nichts weiter beschäftigen und dann hat er sich einfach schwarze Körper angeschaut, was die denn so tun.
Das ist übrigens eine interessante Frage. Also es stimmt, dass der Lehrer in München Planck gesagt hat, Physik lohne sich nicht mehr, es sei nur noch ein Bläschen und Stäubchen und so aus dem Raum zu kehren und dann sei alles klar. Dann sei die so gefestigt wie die Geometrie des Euklids. Das ist alles ganz richtig. Das erzählt jeder und die Geschichte kennen Sie auch, aber Sie müssen mir jetzt erklären, warum Planck trotzdem studiert hat. Denn wenn Sie heute zu jemandem gehen und sagen, versuchen Sie gar nicht mit Computern zu arbeiten, ist alles schon da, warum machen Sie trotzdem weiter?
Naja weil das wahrscheinlich nicht stimmt.
Ja aber woher wissen Sie das in dem Moment?
Man ahnt das vielleicht, keine Ahnung.
Ja aber was ahnt man. Das ist eine spannende Frage. Also Planck macht weiter, kommt mit diesem Quantum dahergelaufen, aber dann ist ruhig. Erstmal fünf Jahre lang passiert gar nichts und dann kommt dieser berühmte Albert Einstein, den wir schon erwähnt hatten und hat eine Idee, dass diese Quanten, die Planck eingeführt hat, als mathematische Größe physikalisch real sind. Nämlich das sind die Teilchen des Lichts, wie man heute sagt. Das hat ein kleines Problem, das Licht war als Welle identifiziert. Und jetzt sagt Einstein, aber es besteht auch aus Teilchen, nämlich Quanten-Teilchen. Und jetzt hat man das Problem, dass Lichtwelle und Teilchen zu gleich ist. Und Einstein sagt, das kann eigentlich nicht sein und er hatte das Gefühl, dass ihm der Boden unter den Füßen verloren geht. Und heute nennt man das Dualität oder Dichotomie des Lichtes, aber dahinter steckt die merkwürdige Idee, dass Physik so ist wie Philosophie, nämlich sie kann Fragen stellen, die man nicht beantworten kann. In der Philosophie können Sie beliebig viele Fragen stellen, die Sie nicht beantworten können. Was ist Wahrheit? Was ist Gerechtigkeit und so weiter? Aber in der Physik hat man immer gedacht, kann ich alles beantworten. Was ist Licht, was ist Ladung, was ist Elektrizität? Kann ich beantworten. Und jetzt stellt Einstein fest, nein kann ich nicht.
Das hat ihm ja schwer zu schaffen gemacht nicht wahr?
Das hat ihm unendlich zu schaffen gemacht. Bis zum Ende, 50 Jahre lang hat er gesagt. Also von 1905 bis 1955. Da ist er gestorben, hat 50 Jahre lang über die Frage nachgedacht, wie dieses Lichtteilchen aussieht und er hat es nicht rausgekriegt und da kommen wir gleich drauf. Dann ist 1905, aber das ist immer noch nicht so.
Ich finde das bloß interessant, dass ja eigentlich diese Zeit so sehr durch Einsteins Arbeit so geprägt ist. Wenn man sich sozusagen primär erst mal daran erinnert, dann denkt man so, ja da kam der Einstein, Relativitätstheorie, alles war anders. Dass aber im Prinzip zeitgleich schon seine Zeitgenossen im Prinzip auch irgendwie an einer Antithese gearbeitet haben, die scheinbar diesem wunderbar belegbaren Werk irgendwie im Tiefsten auch widerspricht, das ist auch irgendwie aus heutiger Sicht noch sehr spannend.
Große Diskrepanz taucht da auf. Das hat Einstein auch geahnt und bis zum Schluss, wenn man so will, auch verflucht. Nämlich die Theorie, die Sie angesprochen haben, ist ja eine Relativitätstheorie, eine Kosmologie, und das ist eine Feldtheorie. Das heißt da redet man von physikalischen Größen, die an jedem Ort der Welt genau definiert sind. Und dann kommen die Quantentheoretiker daher und sagen, da sind Löcher drin. Überall ist sozusagen ein Quantenspruch möglich und das passt irgendwie nicht zusammen. Und Einstein war völlig der Meinung, dass alles kontinuierlich durch ein Feld beschrieben werden kann und er hat zum Beispiel den Einwand von Wolfgang Pauli nicht so ernst genommen, dass Pauli gesagt hat, diese Sache mit dem Feld, dem durchgehenden, wird schwieriger, wenn ich in ein Atom hineingehe. Denn Physik muss immer etwas angeben was wir messen können. Sie können in der Physik nicht nur rumspinnen. Aber sagen Sie mir bitte mal, wie Sie ein Feld in einem Atom messen. Das geht nicht, weil das Gerät aus Atomen besteht, dann können Sie nicht im Atom messen.
Also könnte es sein, dass im Atom etwas ist, was nicht kontinuierlich ist, eben Quanteneffekte. Das ist jetzt aber nur …
Genau wir greifen noch ein bisschen vor.
Jetzt haben wir also, Einstein zeigt, dass der Quantensprung von Planck nicht nur mathematisch nützlich ist, sondern physikalisch wirklich vorhanden ist. Jetzt war aber die Frage, mit der die Leute beschäftigt waren, weil die Chemiker inzwischen eindeutig nachgewiesen hatten, dass es Atome gab, dass es verschiedene Atome gab, wie sehen die eigentlich aus? Das erste Modell war ja, da mussten positive und negative Ladungen sein und man hatte dann das erste Gefühl, dass man sozusagen positiven Brei macht, indem man negative Elektronen reinsteckt. Also Plumpudding oder Rosinenkuchenteig. Und damit hantierte man rum. Und dann kam 1911 das berühmte Experiment von Ernest RUtherford, der hat die damals ziemlich noch neue radioaktive Strahlung genommen, genau genommen Alphastrahlung genommen und die auf eine höchst dünne  Folie geschossen, die ganz dünn verarbeitet war, vielleicht so ein paar tausend oder hundert Schichten von Goldatomen.
Und das war ein Standardexperiment. Normalerweise schießt man so einen Strahl auf so eine Folie und beobachtet die Verteilung des Strahls hinter der Folie. Das nennt man ein Streuexperiment und dann können Sie dort den Streuquerschnitt berechnen und alles mögliche und dann wissen Sie etwas über die Folie, über den Aufbau der Folie. Und beim Messen stellte sich heraus, dass ein Teil der Strahlung zurückkam. Und dann sofort, das ist auch ganz gescheit, das ist ungefähr so, als ob er sagt, ich schieße mit einem Maschinengewehr auf eine Zeitung und mindestens eine Kugel kommt zurück. Das heißt es musste sozusagen in der Zeitung oder in den Atomen musste etwas sein, was Alphastrahlen zurückschießen konnte. Und genau sorgfältiges Analysenexperimente zeigten, dass das Atom zweigeteilt war. Also Sie sehen, das ungeteilte wird jetzt zweigeteilt oder das unteilbare wird zweigeteilt. Und zwar muss es geben, nach Rutherford, einen Kern im Zentrum und ein Elektronengewirr außen. Also das nennt man den Kern und die Elektronenhülle.
Und er nannte das Saturn-Modell und lachte sich darüber kaputt, weil das nach den Gesetzen der klassischen Physik nicht sein dürfte. Die Elektronen kreisten um einen geladenen Kern. Das heißt sie kreisten in einem elektrischen Feld und das bedeutet nach der klassischen Physik, dass die Elektronen Energie verlieren oder abstrahlen. Das ist halt so in der Physik. Maxwellschen Gleichungen sagen das. Und also mussten die Elektronen Energie verlieren, in den Atomkern hineinstürzen und mit anderen Worten, es durfte gar keine Materie geben nach der Physik und nach den Messungen.
Weil es nicht stabil wäre?
Und jetzt gab es zwei Möglichkeiten, entweder war das Modell falsch oder die Physik war falsch. Und jeder von uns hätte gesagt, das Modell ist falsch. Aber ein junger Mitarbeiter von Rutherford, damals in Manchester, das war der Däne Niels Bohr, der hat gesagt, dann ist die Physik eben falsch. Also das Modell ist richtig, das Experiment ist zu gut, das Modell ist richtig, die Physik ist falsch. Und wie kann ich die Physik korrigieren? Aha Hilfestellung ist der Quantensprung von Planck. Er tritt sozusagen erst als klassischer Physiker auf der Bohr, berechnet eine mögliche Elektronenbahn, tritt dann als klassischer Physiker wieder ab und schickt den Quanten-Physiker Bohr vor, der sagt, diese Bahn kann sich nur durch Quantensprung ändern und nicht kontinuierlich. Die klassische Physik sagt voraus, dass sich das kontinuierlich ändert. Die Quanten-Physik sagt aber jetzt, da muss ein Quantensprung sein und der Quantensprung geht nicht von selbst, da muss Energie reingesteckt werden.
Kurz erläutern, der Quantensprung ist wie definiert? Weil das ist ja so ein geflügeltes, was meistens auch noch komplett falsch zitiert wird.
Also Quantensprung ist das was Max Planck eingeführt hat für die Veränderung der Energie, wenn sie von einem Körper ausgestrahlt wird, die geht nicht kontinuierlich von einer Stufe zur anderen, sondern die kann nur sozusagen in Sprüngen erfolgen.
Also in einem zählbaren Maße, also einem quantifizierbaren Maße und daraus leitet sich der Name Quantensprung ab.
Also als es später dann populär wurde. Also in der Physik ist ein Quantensprung das was mit einem Atom passiert, wenn es in einem bestimmten Zustand ist. Zustand ist dann damals als Begriff der Physiker eingeführt worden, für das was ein Atom ausmacht und dann geht das in einen anderen Zustand über, dabei wird Energie frei und diese Energie kommt als Licht raus. Und insofern ist ein Quantensprung das, ein normaler Quantensprung besteht darin, dass etwas von einem hohen Energiezustand in einen tiefen Energiezustand geht, in dem dann sozusagen Ruhe herrscht. Der Quantensprung der Industrie oder der Politik ist genau das Gegenteil. Der geht nach oben und sozusagen in die offene Zukunft. In der Quanten-Physik geht der Quantensprung nach unten in einen stillen Grundzustand. Jetzt sagt Bohr Folgendes: die Elektronen haben ihre Bahn, wie man das klassisch kennt, aber sie können sich daraus nur durch einen Quantensprung bewegen und der geht nicht einfach von selbst, sondern da muss ich von außen was hinzusteuern oder eingeben.
Und auf diesen Quantenbahnen ist Stabilität. Und wie sich herausstellte, kann man das mathematisch sehr genau durchrechnen, da kann man Konstanten angeben und das stimmte genau. Und da gibt es das Bohrsche Atom-Modell, dass Sie alle kennen. Der Kern in der Mitte, die Elektronenbahnen, die außen drumrum kreisen. Das lernt man in der Schule noch kennen, das kennt man als Warnschilder für Radioaktivität, überall sehen Sie das Bohrsche Atom-Modell. Es gibt auch so Wissenschaftssendungen, die sagen, jetzt erklären wir Ihnen die Welt und dann sieht man im Hintergrund so ein Atom-Modell wie Bohr das gebaut hat. So ein paar Klümpchen in der Mitte, die dann Kern sind, und die Elektronen drum kreisen.
Also definitiv eins der ikonischen Bilder, die Wissenschaft jemals geliefert hat.
Und es hat wohl den Nobelpreis gebracht. Es hat
zum ersten Mal erklären können, warum de Atome stabil sind. Es hat den Leuten geholfen, das ganze Periodensystem der Elemente zu erklären. Also grandios. Aber, aber, aber. Von Anfang an wusste Bo, dass das nicht stimmen konnte. Und wer es auch gewusst hat, war später sein Student Heisenberg. Denn was daran nicht stimmen konnte war daraufhin folgendes, sie wollen eigentlich nicht die Atome erklären, sondern sie wollen die Materie erklären, die aus Atomen besteht. Dann können Sie aber nicht die Materie schon in das Atom hineinstecken. Denn wenn Sie sagen, das besteht aus Teilchen, die eine Masse haben und die umeinander kreisen, dann ist die Masse ja schon da, die Sie noch erklären wollen. Das Atom kann nicht anschaulich sein. Wusste Bo schon damals, aber er hatte keine Ahnung, was man machen könnte. Also Sie sehen hier das grundlegende Problem. Sie wollen von Anfang an etwas erklären, dann können Sie aber nicht das was Sie erklären wollen voraussetzen.
Das ist immer wieder ein Fehler, der vorkommt. Selbst in dem ganz großen philosophischen Entwurf von Kant, in der Kritik der reinen Vernunft, möchte er das Denken erklären. Das in Kategorien erfolgt und er setzt dafür die Kategorien voraus. Ist also völlig unbrauchbar, aber das ist ja ein anderes Thema. Und was Bo weiß, er kann nicht Materie voraussetzen und dann sagen, daraus besteht Materie und was Heisenberg, als er das zum ersten Mal sieht, das Bohrsche Atommodell sagt es, das kann nicht sein, denn was wir letzten Endes erklären wollen ist das Planetensystem. Und wenn ich mit einem Planetensystem anfange, brauche ich es nicht mehr zu erklären. Also an dem Bohrschen Atommodell war grundsätzlich etwas falsch, obwohl alle es kennen. Obwohl es die Ikone ist, wie Sie gesagt haben, obwohl jeder damit rechnen konnte, obwohl Sie alle Experimente damit erklären können oder fast alle. Aber irgendwas was an dem Ding grundsätzlich falsch und ist die Frage nur was. Das Bohrsche Atommodell ist von 1913. Da war Heisenberg 12 Jahre alt und nehme mal an, nicht unbedingt damit beschäftigt.
Aber er hat irgendwann angefangen Platon zu lesen, dann hat er angefangen irgendwann sich um mathematische Gleichungen zu kümmern, die da eine Rolle spielen können. Also der war ja ein hochtalentierter Mensch, aber es hat dann doch etwas gedauert. Dann kam die Zeit des Ersten Weltkriegs, da war er mit anderen Fragen beschäftigt, nämlich wie sich die Jugend die Zukunft Europas oder Deutschlands vorstellt, wie man überhaupt in so einem Land lebt. Und dann aber kam irgendwann die Zeit, wo er anfing, zum Studium zu gehen. Und dann tauchte er bei Arnold Sommerfeld auf in dem physikalischen Seminar in der Universität München und jetzt ging das los. Also sagen wir mal etwa 1920. Und von 1920 bis 1924, also vier lange Jahre hat Heisenberg eine Möglichkeit nach der anderen durchgerechnet, um aus dem Bohrschen Atommodell etwas zu machen, was die anderen Gesetze der Physik erklärt. Also das berühmteste Phänomen, das man damals untersuchte, bestand darin, dass man Atome in Magnetfeldern unterbrachte und dann merkte, wie das Licht sich wandelte, das dabei ausgesendet wurde.
Also die Linien des Lichtes. Spektrallinie spalteten sich auf in Duplets, in Triplets und alles mögliche. Das nennt man den Seemann-Effekt und den galt es zu erklären und auch viele andere Dinge, und damit kam er überhaupt nicht zurück mit dem Bohrschen Atommodell. Und da war irgendwas grundsätzlich falsch. Und Heisenberg wusste zum Verrecken nicht, was er nun machte. Aber er rechnete und rechnete und rechnete und dann kam so allmählich das Jahr 1925 näher. Aber vorher ist für Heisenberg etwas ganz wichtiges passiert.
War er da noch an der Uni?
Da war er inzwischen Assistent in Göttingen.
Also nicht mehr in München.
Nicht mehr in München. Vorher ist etwas anderes passiert, das ist vielleicht auch interessant. Das finde ich immer wichtig. Also 1922 ist ein berühmtes Jahr in der Geschichte der Physik, weil der große dänische Physiker Niels Bohr, Nobelpreisträger, der Schöpfer des Atommodells, der große Freund von Albert Einstein. Also wo Bohr Einstein war sozusagen die Konstellation am Himmel der Physik, die strahlende Konstellation, kam nach Göttingen. Das klingt heute banal. Aber erinnern Sie sich bitte dran, wir sind jetzt die Jahre nach dem Ersten Weltkrieg und die Physiker haben gesagt, mit Deutschland nicht mehr. sie lehnen jede Zusammenarbeit mit Deutschen ab, Deutschland war sozusagen isoliert. Das hat Heisenberg nicht gestört in München. Die anderen wussten ja sowieso nicht was los war, nur er konnte das alles rechnen. Aber jetzt kam die Einladung von Max Born Und anderen an Niels Bohr, nach Göttingen zu kommen. Und dann ist tatsächlich Niels Bohr nach Göttingen gekommen und hat 1922 drei große Vorträge in dem Audimax der Universität gehalten oder im großen Hörsaal.
Und Göttingen muss man sich vorstellen, wie Heisenberg das ausdrückt, ist die hohe Schule der Mathematik. Da saßen alle Leute, die konnten alles rechnen, die hatten überhaupt keine Schwierigkeiten, auch die kompliziertesten Gleichungen zu lösen, die kompliziertesten Modelle mathematisch zu fassen. Und jetzt kommt der Bohr. Der Bohr ist eigentlich nicht Mathematiker, sondern so ein intuitiver Erzähler. Und Heisenberg sagt, er hört diese Vorträge da unten und jetzt müssen Sie sich überlegen, der Heisenberg ist ja 21 und unten spricht ein Nobelpreisträger, um ihn herum sitzen die 60-70jährigen Honoratioren der deutschen Wissenschaft und er sagt, man merkte ganz deutlich, dass Bohr im Grunde genommen alles geraten hat. Also so rumgeraten. Und dann kam eine Stelle, also Bohr hält so seine erste große Vorlesung, großes Schweigen. Hält die zweite Vorlesung, großes Schweigen. Dann hält Bohr die dritte große Vorlesung und da kommt er auf den Seemann-Effekt zu sprechen, also diese Ableitung, diese Aufgeilung der Lichtlinien, die man sieht, durch Einfluss von Magnetfeldern.
Warum hieß das denn überhaupt Seemann?
Das hat ein Holländer namens Seemann entdeckt.
Ach so okay.
Das hat kein Seefahrer entdeckt. Mit Z geschrieben. Gibt einen normalen und anormalen, aber das wollen Sie jetzt nicht, so genau wollen wir jetzt hier nicht unterscheiden. Und die haben alle sich da, und Bohr hatte einen Assistenten Kramers und dieser Kramers hatte was rumgerechnet und diese Arbeit von dem Herrn Kramers, die den Zeeman-Effekt erklären sollte, hatte Heisenberg sich vorgenommen und im Seminar bei Sommerfeld sagen wir mal so widerlegt. Sie können auch sagen, er hat ihn in Grund und Boden zertrümmert. Der hat einfach gesagt, das geht so nicht. Und jetzt steht Bohr also in Göttingen und sagt, ja sein Assistent Kramers hätte schon erste Überlegungen angestellt, man wüsste bald wie das geht. Und jetzt müssen Sie sich folgendes vorstellen. Heisenberg ist 21. Audimax voll mit großen berühmten Gelehrten, unten der Nobelpreisträger Bohr. Noch hat sich keiner gemeldet. Und jetzt zeigt Heisenberg auf und sagt, Bohr das stimmt nicht, ich habe das ausgerechnet, was Kramers gemacht hat ist Käse. Also das sind meine Worte. Er hat das sicher vornehmer ausgedrückt.
Und jetzt passiert ein entscheidender Moment in Heisenbergs Leben. Der große Bohr stoppt, hört zu, was der junge Mann da oben sagt, merkt sofort, der weiß wovon er spricht. Der ist ernst, der ist gut und sagt, er möchte ihn bitte nach der Vorlesung treffen und hört dann auf. Also wenn man einen Film drehen würde, würde er das jetzt abbrechen und sagen, ihr könnt nach Hause gehen, ihr versteht sowieso nichts, jetzt kommt der Heisenberg. Und dann kommt der Heisenberg nach der Vorlesung runter und die gehen spazieren in Göttingen. Und Heisenberg hat in seiner Autobiografie geschrieben, mit diesem Spaziergang und diesem Gespräch mit Bohr fing seine eigentliche wissenschaftliche Karriere an. Weil Bohr ihm jetzt öffnete, was man alles denken konnte, was man alles machen sollte. Bohr war auch sehr unglücklich mit diesem Kramers Ansatz, aber das war halt mathematisch konnte man das durch exerzieren, aber er wusste auch, das führt zu nichts.
Aber er ermutigt jetzt Heisenberg. Also jetzt sind wir im Jahr 22, er lädt Heisenberg ein, nach Kopenhagen zu kommen. Was Heisenberg auch tut, mit einem Nebeneffekt, der ganz interessant ist. Der mit Physik aber nichts zu tun hat. Aber den muss ich jetzt erzählen, das ist bei Heisenberg immer wichtig. Das erste, was Heisenberg nämlich macht, wenn er in eine fremde Stadt kommt, ist, er schaut nicht nach dem physikalischen Institut oder er schaut nicht nach einem Hotel oder er schaut nicht nach einer Pizzeria oder so was. Das erste, was Heisenberg tut, wenn er in eine fremde Stadt kommt, fragt er, wo er ein Klavier findet. Er kann ohne Klavierspielen nicht leben. Er braucht das Klavier, er muss Beethoven spielen, er muss Schubert spielen, er muss Mozart spielen. Er braucht das Klavier. Ohne Klavier würde er sterben, ohne Musik würde er sterben. Ohne Musik ist sein Leben sinnlos und er schreibt dann immer auch, erst kommt die Musik, dann kommen die Eltern, dann kommt was anderes und dann die Physik, was natürlich einfach nur freundliches Geschreibe ist. Aber Musik ist alles wichtige.
Und jetzt ist er also in Kopenhagen und das erste was er tut, nämlich er fragt nach einem Klavier. Und was ist die Antwort? Das Klavier steht im Hause der Familie von Weizsäcker. Also er geht in Kopenhagen zu der Familie von Weizsäcker und trifft auf Carl Friedrich von Weizsäcker. Seine Schwester, seinen Bruder Richard von Weizsäcker und ist sozusagen in der deutschen Kultur und spielt Klavier und verliebt sich in die Schwester von Carl Friedrich von Weizsäcker, das ist aber eine eigene Geschichte. Aber er bekommt auch einen Freund fürs Leben, nämlich Carl Friedrich von Weizsäcker, der später sein Student wird. Lassen wir es mal an der Stelle mal kurz stehen. Also Heisenberg arbeitet jetzt wie verrückt an seiner Rechnung. Er kommt da natürlich auch nicht weiter. Bohr ermutigt und ermutigt, aber das wird dann nichts. Heisenberg geht zurück nach München, promoviert dann und wird Assistent bei Max Born in Göttingen. Und jetzt kommt das Frühjahr 1925.
Im Frühjahr 1925 ist offenbar ein derart starker Pollenflug, dass Werner Heisenberg ganz schlimmes Heufieber bekommt und ein völlig verquollenes Gesicht hat, dass er kaum noch aus den Augen sehen kann und Max Born entpflichtet ihn von allen seinen Aufgaben und schickt ihn für zwei Wochen nach Helgoland. Also im Frühjahr 1925 trifft Heisenberg auf Helgoland ein und jetzt kommen die wahrscheinlich wichtigsten zwei Wochen in der Geschichte der Physik, nur wusste man das vorher nicht. Heisenberg hat viel über diese, also im kleinen Kreis, viel darüber berichtet. Er hat zum Beispiel seinem Freund, späteren Freund, Carl Friedrich von Weizsäcker gesagt, auf Helgoland konnte er nichts anderes tun als Spazierengehen und die Quantenmechanik machen und nebenbei hat er auch noch den west-östlichen Divan von Goethe auswendig gelernt, also in zwei Wochen. Und neben der Quantenmechanik, neben dem Spazierengehen, Heisenberg steht auf den Felsen, schaut sich den Horizont an, träumt von der Unendlichkeit und ist davon überzeugt in dem Moment, dass das Erkenntnisvermögen des Menschen unendlich ist und er das jetzt vollziehen kann.
Also ich glaube, dass man das so romantisch emphatisch sehen muss. also außerdem schwillt sein Gesicht langsam ab. Und jetzt ist folgendes. Ihm ist die ganze Zeit ja klar gewesen, er hat seit vier Jahren an diesem Bohrschen Atommodell rumgerechnet und das klappte vorne und hinten nicht. der hat wirklich alles gerechnet. Also wenn Heisenberg sagt, der hat da vier Jahre lang gerechnet, dann würden wir 400 Jahre dafür brauchen, um das alles nachzuvollziehen. Es gibt keine neue Rechenmöglichkeit mehr. Aber er brauchte einen ganz neuen Blickwinkel. Und dieser Blickwinkel, den kriegt er durch eine briefliche Bemerkung von Wolfgang Pauli.
Seinem alten Freund.
Dem alten Teufel. Sozusagen seinem alter Ego, das da nur drauf wartet. Aber der Pauli möchte auch gerne eine große Idee haben, aber wie kann man das machen? Und jetzt kommt die eigentliche kleine Idee von Pauli, die klingt ganz einfach, die klingt ganz simpel, aber damit ändert sich alles. Die Idee von Pauli heißt, nehmen wir doch mal an, dass Atome überhaupt kein Aussehen haben. Haben Sie den Satz verstanden? Also ich meine, die Bohrsche Atommodellphysik ging immer davon aus, dass Atome eine Figur haben, eine Gestalt, ein Aussehen haben und ich fange mit dieser Gestalt an. Und Pauli sagt, vielleicht gibt es die gar nicht. Vielleicht gibt es so was wie eine Form, wie wir sie kennen gar nicht oder einen Nachteil. Und Heisenberg formuliert das dann so um in diese schöne Form, vielleicht existiert die Bahn eines Elektrons nur dadurch, dass ich sie beschreibe.
Mit anderen Worten, das Atom ist nicht etwas was vorliegt in der Form, sondern dem ich eine Form gebe. Das Atom ist meine Erfindung. Nun kann ich dich beliebig erfinden. Ich muss drauf achten, dass die experimentellen Daten übereinstimmen und was jetzt Heisenberg sagt ist, er macht jetzt folgendes. Er macht jetzt eine Theorie, in der kein einziger Gedanke über das Aussehen des Atoms vorkommt, sondern in dem nur die Messergebnisse vorkommen, die man hat. Der drückt immer ganz lieb, er hat sich da nur an den Messergebnissen orientiert. Aber der eigentliche Gedanke ist …
Also er befreit sich eigentlich von den existierenden Gedankenmodellen.
Das Wort befreien ist genau richtig. Und er beschreibt in seiner Autobiografie was er macht. Der erste Satz da sagt, er löst sich von allem Ballast. Wissen Sie, wie man das in der Mystik nennt? Er reinigt sich. Eine Waschung. Was er macht, er kommt auf Helgoland an und säubert sich, er reinigt sich, er macht eine Waschung. Er schmeißt den Ballast von sich, er bleibt ganz alleine. Und dann überlegt er sich, was er eigentlich wissen will. Nämlich er will wissen, wie die verschiedenen Energieformen, die gemessen werden, korreliert sind, zusammenhängen. Also schreibt er die mal alle auf. Und während er die aufschreibt merkt er, dass dabei so ein Muster entsteht. Und plötzlich sieht er, dass dieses Muster eine Rechenoperation erlaubt. Also heute nennt man das eine Matrix. Das kannte er gar nicht, den Begriff. Er hat das erfunden.
Er erfindet die Sprache neu. Und plötzlich kann das alles zusammensetzen und sehen, dass dabei etwas funktioniert. Aber der entscheidende Moment in meinem Verständnis von Heisenbergs kreativer Idee ist, er stellt sein System zusammen. Er nimmt die gleiche Information, die er hat. Er weiß auch ungefähr, wie so bestimmte Schwingungen überhaupt nur stattfinden können. Also da muss schon eine Menge Kenntnis dabei sein. Und plötzlich hat er ein Muster, das ihm - jetzt kommt der Ausdruck, der ist von ihm - keine Freiheit mehr gibt. Und in dem Moment weiß er, dass er die Wahrheit kennt. Die kennen die Wahrheit, die sind nicht Kreativität, in dem sie machen was sie wollen. sie sind kreativ, indem sie gezwungen werden, von der Sache, die sie jetzt verstehen wollen. Kreativität heißt gezwungen werden, das zu tun was nötig ist. In derselben Zeit gibt es einen Komponisten Arnold Schönberg, der sagt, die Komposition muss so sein, dass es keine freie Note mehr gibt.
Heisenberg durfte keinen freien Schritt mehr gehen, es musste alles aus der Sache vorbestimmt sein, und das findet er jetzt. Und jetzt rechnet er die ganze Nacht durch und morgens um drei hat er es geschafft und es stimmt alles.
Es gab die mathematische Methode der Matrixrechnung zu diesem Zeitpunkt noch nicht?
Die kannte er nicht. Die gab es schon, das ist 19. Jahrhundert. Was meinen Sie, was es alles gibt, was wir einfach nicht kennen? Also als er nach Göttingen zurückkommt sieht sein Lehrer Born, das ist doch eine Matrix. Sagt Heisenberg, …
Hättest du mir auch schon mal früher sagen können.
Also das ist eine andere Geschichte, dass man vielleicht auch zu viel wissen kann.
Aber was hat er denn jetzt sozusagen rausgefunden?
Also er hat ein Schema herausgefunden, wie er das Licht, was Atome aussenden, verstehen kann. Er kann es voraussagen. Er kann die Energie beschreiben. Er hat plötzlich genau verstanden, was da wichtig ist bei den Atomen, ohne dass er ein Modell gemacht hat. Und er hat nur ein mathematisches Schema. Also er nennt das eine Energietabelle. Er hat nur die Matrix vor sich und gerät derart außer Fassung, dass er morgens um drei Uhr natürlich nicht mehr schlafen kann. Er verlässt sein Zimmer und klettert auf einen Felsen, den es leider heute nicht mehr gibt. Weil Helgoland im Zweiten Weltkrieg von den Briten besetzt worden ist, die haben den Felsen gesprengt. Also ich sage Ihnen Brexit … die Briten hätten das lassen sollen, dann hätten wir den Felsen noch, jetzt können wir nicht mehr da hinklettern. Aber was Heisenberg tut, er klettert auf den Felsen und wartet auf den Sonnenaufgang. Das klingt jetzt sehr kitschig romantisch, aber der wesentliche Punkt ist, dass der Felsen sehr schwierig zu klettern war und eigentlich war das etwas todesmutig, was er gemacht hat.
Und was ich persönlich glaube, dass er in dem Moment diese große selige Sehnsucht aus dem westöstlichen Diwan sich erfüllt, die ja heißt, wenn du das nicht hast, dieses stirb und werde, bist du nur ein trüber Gast auf der dunklen Erde. Und das macht er jetzt. Er klettert darauf, stirbt dabei, ist oben und bei Sonnenaufgang wird er der neue Mensch. Das ist der neue Mensch, der neue Heisenberg, die neue Welt, die neue Physik. Ich glaube, man kann sich das gar nicht dramatischer vorstellen. Denn was jetzt passiert ist, er hat ein völlig neues Weltbild und eine völlig neue Ökonomie über alle möglichen Möglichkeiten. Also das ist eine unglaubliche Geschichte. Also was er jetzt gefunden hat, das ist jetzt etwas schwierig insgesamt darzustellen. Also Sie können das ….
Wir müssen ja ohne Gleichungen auskommen.
Er schreibt danach einen Aufsatz. Also die Umdeutung, etwas komplizierter Titel, den er da benutzt. Ich persönlich glaube nicht, dass man das wirklich verstehen kann, was da einer schreibt. Aber wenn ein Genie seine Genialität einfach darlegt, dann sind wir nicht in der Lage, das zu verstehen. müssen wir auch nicht. Verstehen Sie jeden Text von Hegel oder von Schleiermacher oder so. Wenn die Leute wirklich sprechen, in den Tiefsten ihrer Gedanken, dann können wir immer nur sagen, toll. Und bei Heisenberg genauso. Was der Born, sein Lehrer, zustandebringt ist, er kann daraus eine schöne Gleichung machen. Und was da rauskommt ist das entscheidende an der Gleichung, was Heisenberg entdeckt ist, dass offenbar ein großer Unterschied ist, ob ich als Physiker erst den Ort eines Atoms bestimme und dann seine Geschwindigkeit oder umgekehrt, erst die Geschwindigkeit und dann seinen Ort. Je nachdem kommt was anderes raus. Aber der entscheidende Gag, den Heisenberg wieder entdeckt hat, ist der Unterschied dabei.
Also Sie haben ja das Gefühl, Sie machen eine Ortsmessung und eine Geschwindigkeitsmessung. Die Geschwindigkeitsmessung oder Ortsmessung und dann ziehen Sie das ab voneinander diese Produkte und dann kommt was raus, was eine Zahl sein sollte. Ist aber keine Zahl. Was da rauskommt ist eine imaginäre Einheit. Heisenberg entdeckt in dem Moment, dass die Beschreibung der Wirklichkeit nur mit Zahlen gelingt, die nicht zu dieser Wirklichkeit gehören. Sie können das ein Transzendenzphänomen nennen. Heisenberg merkt, dass die Beschreibung der Welt nicht aus der Welt selbst möglich ist. Sondern nur, indem ich in eine andere steige und von da auf die Welt schaue. Das sind die komplexen Zahlen. Das können Sie natürlich profaner sagen. Sie brauchen nicht sozusagen in göttliche Höhen zu steigen, aber das kommt alles in dem Moment aus Heisenbergs Gehirn raus. Das ist alles sozusagen in seinem jahrelangen Nachdenken und mit den mathematischen Fähigkeiten zusammen gewachsen und plötzlich steht es als eindeutige einfache Gleichung da und man kann nur staunen.
Damit habe ich die Kreativität insgesamt noch nicht beschrieben, aber ich habe nur drauf hingewiesen, dass da ein ganz großer entscheidender Schritt in einem jungen Mann gelungen ist, von dem man meiner Ansicht nach sehr viel mehr wissen müsste.
Das heißt wenn ich es richtig verstehe, er hat sich quasi die bis dahin existierenden Modelle, wie man sich quasi Atome und damit ja sozusagen auch die Vorstellung von Materie und dem Wesen der Welt an sich sozusagen vorgestellt hat, zunächst einmal beiseite gestellt. Sich nicht von irgendwelchen Modellen leiten lassen, wo man immer nur versucht, genau diese Modelle zu belegen und es gelingt nicht. Sondern er hat sozusagen einen frischen Ansatz gewählt und dabei festgestellt, dass man eben auf dieses Atom anders blicken muss und dass es sich sozusagen in gewisser Hinsicht auch gar nicht genau beschreiben lässt? Weil immer zwei Dinge das eine immer dem anderen ausweicht. Also der Ort?
Ja dahinten fängt eine ganz spannende Sache, nämlich später nennt man das dann Frage der Anschaulichkeit. Die Atome sind eben nicht anschaulich. Elektronen sind auch nicht anschaulich. Das klingt zwar so, als ob Sie sagen, das ist ein kleines Teilchen. Also früher in der Schule hat man immer gesagt, das ist eine kleine grüne Kugel und dann nehmen Sie die Kugel weg und das Grüne weg, was dann übrig bleibt ist das Elektron. Und das ist nicht mehr so, da ist irgendetwas reales oder wirkliches, aber ob das sozusagen eine Anschaulichkeit hat ist völlig umstritten und eher muss es unanschaulich sein und deshalb ich Heisenbergs Physik unanschaulich. Das hat unangenehme Seiten. Sie können nicht mehr erwarten, also wir würden ja gerne die Atome zeigen, ich würde gerne hier in die Tasche greifen und ich zeige Ihnen hier ein Atom, also es gibt so diese hübsche Anekdote später, als Otto Hahn in Berlin die Kernspaltung entdeckt. Da kommt ein britischer Fotograf vorbei und sagt, Herr Professor Hahn, ich hätte gern zwei Aufnahmen mit Ihnen. Bei der ersten Aufnahme halten Sie den Atomkern in der Hand und bei der zweiten Aufnahme betrachten Sie nachdenklich die Spaltprodukte.
Das geht nicht mehr. Dieser Atomkern ist nicht etwas, was Sie in die Hand nehmen und zeigen können. Und das Kuriose ist, dass Atome einfach keine Dinge sind. Und Heisenberg ist der erste, der das akzeptiert und ernst nimmt. Und jetzt sich so diszipliniert im Denken, dass er die ganze mathematische Struktur ohne diese Vorgabe zustande bringt. Und als er die hat, da hat er sein besonderes Erleuchtungserlebnis, weil er nämlich sagt, also er hat diese Gleichung plötzlich vor sich. er hat gesehen, er kann alle Experimente, alle Duplets, alles kann er berechnen in diesem !!br0ken!! Er versteht natürlich nicht genau, wo das herkommt. Aber in dem Moment, sagt er, hat er das Gefühl, dass die Natur eben ein symbolisches Tablett serviert hat, durch das er hindurchschauen kann, um zu sehen, wie die Natur wirklich operiert.
Das heißt er kann durch diese Gleichungen, er sagt dann, nach unten schauen, um die Natur zu erleben. Und wissen Sie was ich glaube, was er dadurch ausdrückt? Es gibt den berühmten Meister Eckhard, den Mystiker des 14. Jahrhunderts. Der hat sein Gotteserlebnis so gehabt, aber dadurch dass er nach oben geblickt hat. Was Heisenberg jetzt hier hat ist ein mystisches Naturerlebnis und deshalb steht da unten. Bei Heisenberg zählt jedes Wort. Er schaut nach unten durch die Gleichung nicht nach oben. Wenn Sie eine Gleichung haben und die richtige Lösung, dann gucken Sie nach oben. Heisenberg guckt nach unten. weil oben ist Gott, da waren die Mystiker schon. Das ist er nicht, er ist kein Mystiker. Aber er hat ein Einheitserlebnis. Und deshalb sagt Heisenberg, er hat dort seine Prophezeiung erfüllt in dem Moment, dass die Physik im 20. Jahrhundert die Kultur ist, in der die Menschen in der Lage sind, der Wahrheit gegenüber zu treten. Und das tut er in dem Moment.
Im 19. Jahrhundert, in der Romantikzeit war das die Musik. Das war seine Meinung. Deshalb hat er sich ja, das ist auch eine schöne Stelle in der Autobiografie, für die Physik entschieden. Er konnte ja fantastisch Klavier spielen und alles mögliche. Da hat ihn jemand gefragt, warum studierst du nicht Musik und machst da weiter? Da hat er gesagt, er sucht die Möglichkeit eben der Wahrheit gegenüber sein zu können und das ging im 19. Jahrhundert mit der Musik, aber im 20. Jahrhundert geht das wahrscheinlich mit der Physik und deshalb entscheide ich mich für die Physik. Das ist natürlich ein riesiger Anspruch. Aber er kann ihn an dieser Stelle einlösen und deshalb kann er das auch erzählen, dass er im Nachhinein erzählt ist ja nicht … aber ich finde das großartig. Ich finde, das ist sozusagen das Genie unserer Tage und ich könnte immer wieder weiter schwärmen.
Also man könnte sagen, die Quantenmechanik, die er jetzt quasi in dieser Nacht in Helgoland erstmalig beschrieben hat, war quasi so ein bisschen der Notenschlüssel zur Beschreibung zur Komposition für die Welt ja?
Das ist eine gute Beschreibung. Er hat sozusagen dann den Notenschlüssel gefunden oder er weiß jetzt …
Wo die Linien liegen und jetzt kann man irgendwie anfangen.
Er kann auch Schauspielen, er kann auch das Lied dazu singen, die Harmonie finden.
Aber es war so ein bisschen unbefriedigend dann sozusagen, also diese Quantenmechanik.
Es ist völlig unanschaulich. Aber es gab auch Leute, die hassten das wie die Pest. Also der berühmteste Hasser war der große Physiker Erwin Schrödinger, der voller Wut - also Heisenberg hat kein Lob bekommen, also das nicht, Heisenberg endlich hast du es geschafft, sondern du Idiot. Du verdirbst unsere klassische Physik, du bringst imaginäre Zahlen hier rein, die keiner versteht. Du bringst Operatoren hier rein, die wir nicht haben wollen. Denn in den Heisenberg-Gleichungen kommt nichts messbares vor. Die Messbarkeit müssen sie erst wieder berechnen.
Hat ihn denn überhaupt einer geglaubt?
Born. Max Born sofort.
War das jetzt ein Werk, was eigentlich ignoriert wurde und alle so, ja schön, dass du da ein bisschen gerechnet hast, aber wir wissen nicht, wovon du redest? Oder gab es irgendetwas überzeugendes, wo alle gesagt haben, naja das scheint schon irgendwas mit der Realität zu tun zu haben, auch wenn wir noch nicht verstehen warum.
Also Max Born hat sofort verstanden und ein dritter Physiker noch Pascual Jordan, die haben das zusammengefasst und dann die entsprechende Formel angegeben, aber es ist so neu, da können Sie nicht erwarten, dass die Leute sofort aufspringen und sagen, hurra. Also wenn eine Idee wirklich revolutionär ist, dann braucht es eine Zeit, bis ein paar Leute die verstehen. Also wenn eine Idee einfach ist, verstehen alle sofort. Aber so schwieriger Sachen brauchen Zeit. Und Sie müssen ja noch überlegen, wir reden von fünf Leuten. Was Sie ja meinen ist 1000 Leuten, die an den Instituten arbeiten und dann 10.000 Leute, die das studieren. Bis das soweit ist, das dauert noch viel länger.
Was war denn jetzt sozusagen, was würden Sie denn sagen, ist denn die Kernerkenntnis dieser Arbeit gewesen. Also was hat eigentlich, wenn man es jetzt mal versucht auf einen Satz runterzubringen, was hat er durch diese Arbeit 1925 und in den Jahren danach, also mit dieser Definition, dieser mathematischen Definition der Quantenmechanik, was war die Aussage und warum gefiel es den anderen nicht?
Also es gibt eine mathematische Struktur, mit der ich das alles beschreiben kann, aber die mathematische Struktur handelt von Größen, die nicht messbar sind und die mit Zahlen operieren, die nicht auf dieser Welt existieren, sondern in einer imaginären Sphäre. Aber diese imaginären Zahlen kannten die Physiker spätestens seit dem 19. Jahrhundert. Also Gauss hat die dann sehr ausführlich ausgearbeitet. Also Leibniz kannte das zum Beispiel auch, aber hat das überhaupt nicht zur Kenntnis genommen, also weil Sie soeben von dem gesprochen haben, das war den Leuten viel zu unheimlich. zahlen, die sozusagen nicht wirklich waren, also die man nicht messen konnten. Also da gibt es diese imaginäre Einheit I, Wurzel aus -1, da hat man irgendwie das Gefühl, das kann mit Physik nichts zu tun haben. Und was Heisenberg sagt, das hat alles mit Physik zu tun. Die ganze Physik kommt aus dieser Spähre. Also alles was hier abläuft kann nur über solche imaginären Zahlen berechnet werden, die in komplexen Räumen definiert sind. Also das ist trickreich. Was er wirklich …
Aber ließ sich denn irgendwas belegen?
Was er wirklich gefunden hat ist erstens … ja sicher, also er konnte alle Zeeman-Effekte konnten jetzt berechnet werden. Es war einfach völlig klar. Und jetzt kommt der wichtigste Punkt, da wollte ich gerade drauf kommen. Das wird oft in den Geschichten etwas unterschlagen. Ihre Frage ist nämlich sehr wichtig. Die Heisenberg-Gleichung ist da und die Frage ist, da hat kurz danach ein Herr Schrödinger eine ähnliche Form aufgebaut und die war aber genauso kompliziert, nämlich mit imaginären Zahlen und alles Gewusel und dann sind zwei Leute hergekommen, ein Herr Walter Heitler und ein Herr Fritz London, die haben gezeigt, dass damit die Existenz von Molekülen erkläret werden kann.
Heisenberg und Schrödinger zusammen. Also die sind äquivalent die Theorien, mit denen kann man jetzt beiden rechnen. Und jetzt konnten sie plötzlich real was beweisen, nämlich die Existenz von Molekülen. Also sie haben ein Wasserstoff und noch ein Wasserstoff und plötzlich sind die zusammen und dann müssen sie begründen, warum das stabil ist das Molekül. Das war vorher völlig undenkbar und jetzt war das völlig klar und sie konnten auch noch andre Sachen berechnen, also die Wechselwirkung der Materie mit elektrischen Feldern. irgendwann konnten sie auch überhaupt die Leitfähigkeit von Materie berechnen und plötzlich war das alles völlig klar. Sie konnten verstehen, warum manche Stoffe Leiter sind, manche Stoffe Halbleiter sind, warum Glas durchsichtig ist. Also alles das was sie so wissen, aber vorher nie erklären konnten, hier ist die Erklärung. Sie müssen immer die Quantenphysik anwenden. Mit der Quantenphysik können Sie alles erklären. Deshalb war ja auch später jemand der Meinung, wir brauchen die anderen Wissenschaften nicht mehr, wir brauchen nur die Grundlagen der Quantenmechanik, dann können wir alles andere ausrechnen.
Also mit der Arbeit von Heisenberg?
War das Heisenberg zu dem Zeitpunkt schon klar, als er das geschaffen hat? Eigentlich nicht, er hat sich ja freigemacht. Er hat sozusagen einfach nur gesagt, ich gehe von dem aus, was ich so bisher beobachten kann.
Das ist eine schwierige Frage. Also sie haben natürlich als junger Wissenschaftler, der noch keine Professur hat, haben sie natürlich nur Angst, dass das falsch ist. Also so selbstbewusst, dass sie sozusagen die Wahrheit gefunden haben, das sind sie nur in ihrem Herzen. Und das muss sich jetzt erst mal erweisen. Aber nach und nach wird das immer klarer und 1927 war das völlig klar. Also nach zwei Jahren war klar, dass da was ganz großes gelungen war und dann hat Heisenberg ja noch eins drauf gesetzt, nämlich die Unbestimmtheitsrelation, die von 1927 dann kommt. Aber die Leute waren damals der Meinung, hatten gewusst, jetzt haben sie was ganz neues verstanden, was ganz neues begriffen und auch eine ganz neue Weltsicht. Aber das mussten die jetzt alle auch mal lernen. Also machen wir mal die kuriose Sache, selbst Max Planck, der eigentliche Initiator dieser Quantenwelt, hat die Mathematik nicht mehr mitgemacht. Und er hat auch deshalb gesagt, eine neue Theorie setzt sich nicht dadurch durch, dass die Vertreter der alten überzeugt werden. Sondern die setzt sich dadurch durch, dass die Vertreter der alten sterben.
Um das noch so ein bisschen aus meiner laienhaften Betrachtung zusammenzufassen, was eigentlich passiert ist. Es gab das Bohrsche Modell, es gab von Bohr selber Zweifel an diesem Modell. Er wusste, dass er sich bestimmte Dinge nicht erklären kann und jetzt kam Heisenberg mit seinen hohen mathematischen Fähigkeiten, der sich mit einem speziellen Phänomen, nämlich diesem Zeeman-Effekt, was ja letzten Endes die Änderung von Spektrallinien durch Magnetfelder ist, also es gab da einen atomaren Effekt, den man sich nicht erklären kann und der hat ihn sozusagen als solchen in sich aufgenommen und in irgendeiner Form dieser Selbstreinigung sozusagen in so ein mathematisches Modell überführt, was das, was dort beobachtet werden kann, erklärte. Und dann im Nachgang, als sich das alle angeschaut haben, hat man festgestellt, holla das passt ja nicht nur dafür. also es ist jetzt nicht nur durch Zufall etwas, was genau das beschreibt, sondern offensichtlich ist hier ein Modell gefunden worden, was auch alles andere beschreibt und auf einmal sind Dinge erklärbar geworden, die vorher so nicht erklärbar waren.
Sie haben völlig recht. Ich würde nur das Wort Modell, also außer beim Bohrschen Modell, würde ich das Wort Modell durch Sprache ersetzen. Er hat eine Sprache gefunden, mit der ich darüber sprechen kann. Eine mathematische Sprache klar, aber er verzichtet ja geradezu auf Modelle, also auf irgendeine Form von Anschaulichkeit. Anschaulichkeit ist sozusagen der Feind der Wahrheit.
Okay gut. Eine Sprache.
Das ist übrigens, insofern finde ich das mit der Unanschaulichkeit des Atommodells und dem Nichtaussehen des Atom insofern spannend, das ist ja ungefähr die Zeit, wo auch die abstrakte Malerei entsteht und wie die Baumeister, einer der großen Vertreter der abstrakten Malerei, hat in einer Arbeit, aber die ist etwas später erschienen, die Frage gestellt, ob Natur überhaupt ein Aussehen hat. Es könnte ja sein, dass man das Aussehen der Natur nur dadurch findet, dass der Künstler im Dunkel der Wirklichkeit gerbt. Und das hat Heisenberg gemacht. Die Natur und die Atome haben kein Aussehen, die Natur hat auch kein Aussehen. Die moderne Kunst macht dafür die abstrakte Malerei und Heisenberg macht die abstrakte Quantenmechanik, das ist sozusagen dieselbe kulturelle Leistung. Und Heisenberg weiß das. Also ich könnte mir ein Gespräch vorstellen, einen Spaziergang am Starnberger See zwischen Werner Heisenberg und Vasily Kandinsky. Die darüber sprechen, wie eigentlich die Wirklichkeit darzustellen ist.
Weil beide machen dasselbe abstrakt. Der eine mit Punkt, Linien, Flächen, Farben und der andere mit mathematischen Formeln. Aber letzten Endes ist es dieselbe Aufgabe, nämlich der Wirklichkeit näher zu kommen, der Wahrheit gegenüber treten zu können und bei Heisenberg hat man nur den Vorteil, dass das was er berechnen kann, dann im Experiment geprüft werden kann und immer sich als richtig herausstellt. Und das ist natürlich, da ist er triumphierend. Aber trotzdem bis das natürlich im Lehrbuch ist, das dauert was. Aber klar ist, das ist jetzt der wichtige Punkt, dass man mithilfe dieser Gleichung überhaupt in der Lage ist, zum Beispiel die Leitfähigkeit von Metallen zu verstehen. Und um auf ein ganz großes Thema zu kommen, das sich jetzt aber am Anfang gar nicht sich so anhört, man ist auch in der Lage zu verstehen, was Halbleiter zu Halbleitern macht. Also dass die manchmal leiten und manchmal nicht. Und man kann dann auch verstehen, wie man Halbleiter so verändern kann, dass die mal sozusagen positiver sind, mal negativer sind und wenn sie die dotierten Halbleiter zusammenschaufeln.
Das können sie nur, wenn sie Quantenmechanik können, kriegen sie einen Transistor und wenn sie einen Transistor kriegen, kriegen sie einen Chip und wenn sie Chips haben, kriegen sie ihr Handy und das Handy von Heisenbergs Nacht auf Helgoland ab.
Inwiefern. Also wir hatten das ja schon, dass Einstein mit dieser Quantenmechanik so nichts anfangen konnte. Was war denn eigentlich der Grund dafür?
Also er hat die Quantenmechanik selbst sozusagen aufs Pferd gesetzt und dann losreiten lasen. Aber dabei sind ihm ein paar Sachen in die Quere gekommen. Also eins ist, das Wort ist noch nicht gefallen, was Heisenberg beschreibt ist ja nicht der Ort eines Elektrons, sondern die Wahrscheinlichkeit ein Elektron an einem Ort zu finden. also es geht jetzt nicht mehr, dass die Physik voraussagt was ist, sondern die voraus berechnen kann eine Wahrscheinlichkeit, dass ein Ereignis eintritt, wenn ich das messe. Das ist natürlich sehr viel weniger als das was man früher gedacht hat. Und Einstein ist eigentlich noch klassische Physik, auch G. Planck. Die möchten gerne,dass die Physik berechnet was da ist. Und Heisenberg hat gesagt, wir können nur berechnen die Wahrscheinlichkeit mit der wir beim Messen etwas herausbekommen. Das ist was ganz anderes. Das ist übrigens eine ganz gnadenlose Unterscheidung, die an dieser Stelle kurz danach Niels Bohr treffen wird. Früher hat man immer geglaubt, dass Physik die Beschreibung der Natur ist. Und Sie würden heute das auch noch unterschreiben. Wenn ich Ihnen das sage, würden Sie sagen, ja.
Klingt jetzt erstmal nicht so falsch.
Nein ist sie aber nicht. Physik ist die Beschreibung unseres Wissens von der Natur und das ist was anderes. Also das ist der entscheidende Unterschied. Und Heisenberg führt das vor. Bohr exerziert das nach und die Sachen zeigen sie. Und jetzt passiert folgendes, die Physik sagt nicht mehr voraus, wo ein Teilchen ist, sondern sagt nur die Wahrscheinlichkeit voraus, mit der sie ein Teilchen an einem Ort messen können, wenn sie unter bestimmten Bedingungen die Messungen durchführen und das fand Einstein falsch. Sein Argument war immer so, dass es eine physikalische Beschreibung dieses Ortes oder dieser Geschwindigkeit oder dieser Energie geben muss, nur haben wir sie noch nicht. Da wir sie noch nicht haben, ist die Quantenmechanik zwar richtig, für alles das was wir jetzt messen können und berechnen können, aber da fehlt noch etwas. Und das Schlüsselwort von Einstein war, die Quantenmechanik ist unvollständig. Es muss sozusagen im Hintergrund noch irgendwelche Parameter geben, mit denen man das berechnen kann. Das sind die verborgenen Parameter, die es mal gab. Und dann gibt es aber mehrere große Arbeiten dazu, dass es so was nicht geben kann.
Und dann hat Einstein irgendwann gesagt, also er glaubt einfach nicht - und dann kommt dieser berühmte Satz - dass Gott würfelt. worauf dann Niels Bohr gesagt hat, es wäre nicht die Aufgabe der Menschen, Gott vorzuschreiben, wie er die Welt einrichtet.
aber da kommt ja eine interessante Komponente mit rein. Wenn ich das richtig deute, dann ist ja sozusagen Albert Einsteins Streben nach Wissen dadurch geprägt, sozusagen Klarheit zu haben. Einen Determinismus in der Welt zu setzen.
Komischerweise.
Die Leute, die ihn kennen oder seine Biografien geschrieben haben, wenn die gefragt werden, können Sie einem Satz sagen, was Einstein so ausmacht? Dann sagen die immer, das ist der freiste Mensch, den ich jemals gesehen habe. Ich meine Sie wissen das mit der Zunge, mit den Haaren, mit den Socken und alles mögliche. Hat sich nicht die Zähne geputzt und all so ein Zeug. Also ist der freieste Mensch. Also Sie müssen hier anständig auftreten, ich muss auch ein Hemd anhaben. Aber in der Physik wollte er genau das Gegenteil. In der Physik wollte er, dass alles bestimmt ist, alles determiniert ist, alles berechenbar ist. Ich verstehe ihn nicht, aber es ist so. Ich meine, ich verstehe auch meine Frau nicht, warum soll ich Einstein verstehen. Also es ist schwierig, das zu verstehen. Einstein hat sich da viele Gedanken drüber gemacht. Das hat was mit ethischen, mit religiösen Themen zu tun, mit denen er beschäftigt ist. Aber die Idee, dass sozusagen dann nur Wahrscheinlichkeiten berechnet werden können, dass die Natur gewissermaßen machen kann was sie will und dass da Freiheiten drin sind.
Und die exakt zu beschreiben.
Aber das ist jetzt im Prinzip genau das Ergebnis dieser Quantenmechanik von Heisenberg? Dass er eigentlich feststellt, vermutlich lassen sich Dinge nicht mit Bestimmtheit festlegen, aber man kann zumindest mit Wahrscheinlichkeiten arbeiten und vielleicht ist diese Wahrscheinlichkeit eben einfach auch ein Teil dieser Natur?
Ja, genau, das ist ein ganz wichtiger Punkt. Also zunächst mal, die Berechenbarkeit der Quantenmechanik ist nicht in der realen Welt, sondern nur in dieser imaginären Welt. Also in der Welt mit imaginären Zahlen, mit komplexen Zahlen.
Da ist sie genau. Da ist alles vorherbestimmt.
Da ist sie genau.
Aber wenn man sie sozusagen …
Aber wenn man sie dann umrechnet, dann geht ein bisschen verloren und dann kommt die Wahrscheninlichkeitsdimension rein. Also da müssen Sie sozusagen zwei Funktionen miteinander multiplizieren nach einer genauen Vorschrift, die Max Born vorgelegt hat, hat er einen Nobelpreis für gekriegt und dann geht ein bisschen was von der klaren und festen Information aus diesem imaginären Bereich verloren und hier haben Sie dann einen Wackelpudding. Also können Sie ein bisschen so wackeln lassen. Das Verrückte dabei ist, das hat Heisenberg auch immer wieder betont, das fällt ihm natürlich auch schwer, das immer zu glauben, aber er muss halt dieser Physik und diesen Vorhersagen und diesen Gesetzen, die da rauskommen, vertrauen. Da besagt drin, dass die Wahrscheinlichkeit, die da eine Rolle spielt, nicht die Wahrscheinlichkeit des Würfelspiels ist, deshalb ist das Einstein-Modell völlig falsch. Also beim Würfel ist die Wahrscheinlichkeit, dass Sie nicht wissen was rauskommt, dadurch gegeben, dass Sie nicht alle Parameter wissen können, die so einen Würfelfall beeinflussen. Also die Geschwindigkeit, mit der Sie die Hand drehen. Luftwiderstand.
Das ist eine subjektive Wahrscheinlichkeit. Der wesentliche Punkt an der Quantenmechanik ist, dass die Wahrscheinlichkeit in der Sache selbst, also objektive Wahrscheinlichkeit ist. Also Sie können das an einem einfachen Beispiel sich vorstellen. Es gibt ja, das kennen wir alle, so halbversilbertes Glas, also 50% des Lichtes wird reflektiert und 50% wird durchgelassen und jetzt können Sie auch diese halbversilberte Scheibe mit einzelnen Lichtteilchen bombardieren. Dann ist, wie Sie erwarten, was auch rauskommt, die Wahrscheinlichkeit, dass das Lichtteilchen durchgeht, 50%. Aber was das Lichtteilchen tut können Sie nicht voraussagen. Das hängt ja nicht davon ab, dass Sie nicht wissen, was das Lichtteilchen tut, Sie haben es ja genau präpariert. Also Sie haben eingestellt und das alles, Sie haben alles im Griff, aber das Lichtteilchen macht trotzdem was es will, weil die Wahrscheinlichkeit objektiv ist, was immer das jetzt heißt. Also Sie müssen damit rechnen, dass es da Dinge gibt, die uns nicht zugänglich sind und das ist dann die nächste große Entdeckung von Heisenberg von 1927.
Die unter dem Stichwort Unbestimmtheit berühmt geworden ist. Also Unbestimmtheit, er hat ja jetzt gesagt, die Bahn eines Elektrons entsteht nur dadurch, dass wir sie beschreiben, dann ist natürlich trotzdem die Frage, also die ein Freund ihm gestellt hat, ich müsste doch in der Lage sein, ein Elektron unter einem Mikroskop zu beobachten. Ich muss nur das Mikroskop groß genug machen, die Strahlen energetisch genug machen. Und Heisenberg denkt darüber nach und kommt dann zu dem Ergebnis, das Elektron ist ja klein, dann brauche ich hochenergetische Strahlen und dann ist der Zusammenstoß zwischen diesen Strahlen und Elektronen so, dass ich da nicht genau hingucken kann und dann sagt man machmal, das ist eine Unschärfenrelation. also ich kann den Ort des Teilchens oder seine Geschwindigkeit bestimmen, aber nicht beides, aber Heisenberg sieht sofort, dass da noch viel mehr ist. Und das ist die jetzt wirklich eigentliche Entdeckung und die halte ich ja für ganz die zentrale oder wenn Sie die hatten als junger Mann, dann müssen Sie irgendwie gläubig werden oder sonst irgendwas, Sie könnten das nicht.
Die Idee ist, dass das Elektron gar keine Eigenschaft hat, bevor ich sie messe. das heißt das Elektron ist unbestimmt, bis jemand fragt, wo bist du, dann sagt das Elektron, hier. Oder wie schnell bist du, dann sagt das Elektron, so schnell. Wenn Sie ein ganz einfaches Bild dafür wollen, ist das so als wenn Sie in eine Kneipe gehen und Sie wissen nicht genau, Pizza oder Pommes Frites, oder Rot- oder Weißwein oder Bier oder Saft. Sie sind unbestimmt, aber jetzt kommt der Kellner oder der Wirt und sagt, was wollen Sie jetzt, Pizza oder Pommes? Dann sagen Sie, Pommes. In dem Moment sind Sie bestimmt, aber vorher waren Sie unbestimmt und das Elektron auch. Sie sind ja wie ein Elektron, Sie werden bestimmt durch die Frage des Experimentators, in dem Fall des Kellners.
Das heißt die Beobachtung bestimmt sozusagen das Sein?
Sie haben natürlich nicht alle Möglichkeiten. sie haben nur ein paar Möglichkeiten als Elektron. Also Sie können gewissermaßen sich so bewegen oder so bewegen oder was auch immer wir uns darunter vorstellen. Das Elektron ist schwierig zu fassen. Also nur ja kein Kügelchen, das Sie grün anstreichen können.
Brust oder Keule.
Es dreht sich auch noch. Versuchen Sie sich mal, ein Elektron vorzustellen. Das dreht sich, hat eine Ladung, hat eine Masse und ist trotzdem nicht fassbar. Also versuchen Sie mal nicht,… also man hat so das Gefühl, ein kleines Kügelchen, das sich dreht wie eine Billardkugel in rot oder grün oder so was. Aber das ist ganz was anderes und das ist der eigentliche Punkt. Und jetzt kommt für mich die merkwürdige Entdeckung. durch die Unbestimmtheit, das klingt so furchtbar fremd. Also sozusagen da ist ein Elektron, das gar keine Eigenschaft hat, aber ich lege die Eigenschaft fest. Das bedeutet aber natürlich, dass ich und das Elektron eins werden. Denn ich kann nur über das Elektron sprechen, was ich kenne. und das ist für mich, also wenn Sie die Bemerkung gestatten, die Neubelebung des Atombegriffs. Früher war das Atom ein Objekt, jetzt ist es das Atom die Wechselwirkung zwischen mir und der Welt, die ist untrennbar.
Und ich kann nur etwas wissen über die Welt, indem ich mit ihr wechselwirke und dabei muss ich ein Quantum austauschen, so dass das Atom wieder da ist. Es besteht auch zwei Teilen, die Welt und ich wir beide, wir sind ein Atom und dadurch können wir über uns Bescheid wissen und Physik treiben. Also ich meine, jetzt machen Sie daraus keine große Theorie, sondern ist eine nette Floskel, mit der man anfangen kann.
Ich nehme das mal so hin. Erwin Schrödinger hat das ja auch hingenommen, auch wenn er am Anfang noch großer Kritiker war, ist er ja sozusagen mit seinem Bildnis der Katze, von der man nicht weiß, ob sie lebt oder tot ist, hat er ja im Prinzip auch ein Bild dafür geliefert.
Ja das ist für mich völlig unbegreiflich, dass Schrödinger diese Katze da sterben lässt in diesen Kästen. Also hat ein radioaktives Atom drin, das zerfallen kann, dass dann einen Mechanismus auslöst, das ein Giftgas freisetzt und dann ist die Katze tot oder nicht. Und Erwin Schrödinger sagt, die Behauptung der Quantenmechanik ist, dass sie erst dann tot oder lebendig ist, wenn ich hinschaue. Und ich meine, der ist Nobelpreisträger der Schrödinger, ein großer Mann. Aber was Heisenberg gesagt hat, gilt nicht für Katzen, sondern für Atome. Also ob das Atom links oder rechts ist wissen wir nicht, aber ob die Katze lebt…
Er hat ein Bild geliefert, was sozusagen bis heute noch auch die Popkultur maßgeblich beeinflusst.
Ja, also Schrödingers Katze ist ein wunderbares Beispiel. Also Partygespräch, also wie Unbestimmtheit oder Party. Sie können nicht von Determinanten und Matrizen sprechen, dann sagen die Leute, hä? Aber wenn Sie sozusagen Unbestimmtheit sagen, Bohrschen Atommodell kann man auch schon sagen, Sie haben da eine Popkultur, die da entstanden ist und das hat ja auch Vorteile. Auch Quantensprung ist schön, dass das ein Popmodus der Popkultur geworden ist, Sie brauchen nicht jetzt immer von vorne anzufangen. Das Wort Quantum kennt jetzt jeder. Dabei ist der eigentliche Begriff, der quantisiert wird, der ist spannender. Das ist die Wirkung. Das Wirken ist das Produkt aus Energie und Zeit. Und da ist ein ganz kurioses Geheimnis dahinter. Das Geheimnis besteht darin, dass die Energie eigentlich kontinuierlich, die Zeit eigentlich dauerhaft abläuft, aber das Produkt Löcher hat. Aber ich wollte Sie nicht verwirren. Sondern nur sagen, dass da unheimlich viel rätselhaftes und geheimnisvolles ist, was einem gefallen kann.
Übrigens, Heisenbergs Unbestimmtheitsrelation hat ihn auch die ganzen Nächte durch Kopenhagen rennen lassen und nicht verstehen lassen, was er da weiß über die Natur. Der muss unheimlich ein Erleben gehabt haben. Was dann natürlich letzten Endes immer die Frage stellt, wer hilft mir da, wer kann mir da helfen, wem kann ich mich zurück, an wen kann ich mich wenden, um das zu verstehen. Also Einstein spricht in solchen Fällen von kosmischer Religiosität. Heisenberg spricht in dem Fall vom Vertrauen in die zentrale Ordnung. Für ihn war klar, dass es eine zentrale Ordnung gibt, die ist sozusagen innerlich, nicht außen. Also das Kaiserreich ist weg, das Dritte Reich ist eine Katastrophe, aber im Inneren gibt es eine zentrale Ordnung, der kann man vertrauen. Und die teilt sich einem Menschen mit, an der kann er sich orientieren, die kann er beschreiben und dann hat er sozusagen seine Form von Religiosität, also Religiosität der Zurückbindung, ich binde mich zurück an die Ordnung der Welt.
Deshalb gibt es ja auch angeblich den Satz von Heisenberg, den man nur nicht finden kann. Also wenn wir trinken aus dem Becher des Wissens als Atheisten und unten am Boden des Bechers wartet Gott. Aber das ist bei ihm nicht so. Also man kann sich nicht vorstellen, dass er Kirchenlieder gesungen hat, der hat lieber Beethoven gespielt und Schubert.
Kommen wir nochmal so ein bisschen auf Heisenberg und jetzt auch jenseits seines konkreten Schaffens sozusagen seine Rolle auch in der Zeit. Wir hatten das ja schon beleuchtet. Er ist ja quasi nach dem Ersten Weltkrieg überhaupt erst in diese lernende Rolle gekommen und hat quasi zur Weimarer Zeit sein wissenschaftliches Portfolio entwickelt. Und 32 ja dann auch den Nobelpreis erhalten. War das jetzt konkret für die Quantenmechanik?
Ja.
Weil man einfach eingesehen hat, okay hier hat jemand einfach eine Beschreibung geliefert, aus der sich vieles ableiten lässt, auch wenn man sie selber irgendwie so nicht recht erklären kann. Das ist ja eigentlich auch eine interessante Parallele zu Einsteins wirken, der ja zu seinem Zeitpunkt auch diverse Thesen aufgestellt hat. Und es dauerte dann eben erstmal einen Weile, bis erste Beobachtungen überhaupt gemacht werden konnten, die das eben belegen.
Also Einstein hatte das Glück, dass am Ende des Ersten Weltkriegs eine Voraussage von ihm bestätigt wurde und die Stimmung in Europa so war, dass man einen positiven Helden suchte und das wurde dann Einstein. Heisenberg kommt jetzt mit seinen großen Ideen an und das Dritte Reich sich so allmählich aufbaut und alles was dazu gehört sich entwickelt. Also er konnte keine Heldenrolle übernehmen. Also später, aber da war natürlich die Katastrophe des Dritten Reichs und die Katastrophe von Hiroshima, die war vorbei und jetzt konnte man nicht mehr zugucken, ach der hat das gemacht. Also bei Einstein war alles noch sozusagen Hauptsache ein Held, Hauptsache ein neuer Blick auf den Kosmos, aber das wollte man dann bei Heisenberg nicht mehr, aber er hätte das verdient.
Einstein mit seinem jüdischen Hintergrund hat ja dann Deutschland auch schnell verlassen, als er gesehen hat, wie die Dinge sich entwickeln. Heisenberg hat das nicht getan. Heisenberg ist in Berlin geblieben, war dann in Dahlem an der Universität. War dort glaube ich auch Leiter der physikalischen Abteilung, wenn ich das richtig im Sinne habe.
Ja, aber warum Heisenberg in Deutschland bleibt muss man verstehen wo er gewohnt hat.
Ja wo?
In Urfeld am Walchensee.
Wo ist das?
Sie wissen ungefähr wo der Walchensee ist und am Walchensee gibt es …
Nein ich weiß nicht wo der Walchensee ist.
In Oberbayern.
Entschuldigung.
Wenn Sie mal irgendwann Zeit haben, Sie müssen nach Urfeld am Walchensee fahren und an dem Walchensee gibt es einen kleinen Ort namens Urfeld. Überlegen Sie mal was das Wort heißt. Also Heisenberg macht eine Feldtheorie und jetzt trifft er das Urfeld. Wir reden immer von der Urkraft, von der Urwahrscheinlichkeit.
Also hat er sich jetzt diesen Ort so ausgesucht wegen des Namens oder war das Zufall?
Das weiß ich nicht. Ich glaube aber, als er den Namen gesehen hat, wollte er da wohnen. Dann hat er ein Haus gefunden, das hat er Lovis Corinth abgekauft. Und wenn Sie jemals auf der Terrasse dieses Hauses stehen, das gibt es noch, gehört auch heute noch der Familie Heisenberg. Und dann sehen Sie auf den Walchensee und die Kette der Berge dahinter. Da gehen Sie nicht mehr weg. Wo wollen Sie denn hingehen? Nach Kolumbien, nach New York, nach San Francisco? Nein, Sie bleiben am Walchensee. Heisenberg ist in Deutschland geblieben, weil ihm der Walchensee so gefallen hat. Weil er eine Landschaft hatte, die ein Maler gemalt hatte. Er war da, wo Kultur geschaffen worden ist. Heisenberg geht nicht dahin, wo leistungsfähiges Getrampel stattfindet, sondern wo Kultur ist und das war eben Deutschland. Außerdem hatte er inzwischen eine Familie und mehrere Kinder und sie gehen nicht weg. Und abgesehen davon, für alle Leute, die jemals über die Atombombe sprechen, Heisenberg hat sie nicht gebaut, sondern das waren andere.
Also Heisenberg will nur am Walchensee stehen, Klavier spielen, Lovis Corinth anschauen, mit seiner Familie spielen und dann sozusagen von der Physik träumen, aber nicht Atombomben bauen.
Na gut, trotzdem hat er sich natürlich dann im System weiterhin bewegt.
Herr Pritlove, Sie sind ein deutscher Beamter, Sie haben eine Verpflichtung. Heisenberg ist ja kein Schurke, ist ja kein Drückeberger, sondern Sie sind ein deutscher Beamter, Sie müssen Aufgaben erfüllen, Sie übernehmen die Aufgaben, jeder weiß doch wer er ist. Er hat ein Nobelpreis, jeder weiß doch wer er ist, er kann doch nicht weglaufen. Aber er tut natürlich alles, um nun ja nicht das voranzutreiben, da ist so viel Scharlatanerie im Spiel, da ist so viel Abwägen. Ich habe da eine Deutung dafür. Die Deutung ist die, also Heisenberg war der große Physiker auf Helgoland, der den großen Durchbruch erzielt hat. Und der Grund ist der, das steht auch in seiner autobiografischen Beschreibung, bei der wir soeben besprochen haben, dass es mit einer Reinigung anfängt. Nach der Reinigung wartet er noch einen Tag und zwei, um zu warten, bis das Problem in ihm ist. Wenn Sie ein Problem lösen wollen und das ist wirklich schwierig, können Sie das nicht als so eine Aufgabe nehmen, wie ein Beamter, der dann irgendwie eine Steuererklärung berechnet oder so was. Wichtig gar keine Frage.
Aber wenn Sie ein großes Problem wie die Quantenmechanik lösen wollen, muss das innen sein und es kommt dann aus Ihrem Inneren raus. Und hier ist meine These, diese Frage nach der Atombombe hat Heisenberg gar nicht nach innen gelassen. Die hat er als äußeres Problem behandelt, da hat er sich verrechnet, ist in Ordnung, aber er wollte ja auch gar keine Bombe bauen.
Ich habe das Wort der Atombombe noch gar nicht in den Mund genommen, ich hatte es auch ehrlich gesagt gar nicht auf den Lippen. Sondern ich habe mich sozusagen überhaupt erst mal gefragt, wie hat er die Entwicklung der Gesellschaft gesehen zu der Zeit und wie hat er seine eigene Rolle darin definiert?
Also bei der Entwicklung der Gesellschaft hat er … also schreibt er nicht sehr viel in seiner Autobiografie, er macht da nur so allgemeine Bemerkungen. Aber es gibt einen Text von ihm aus dem Jahre 1942, Ordnung der Wirklichkeit, ein sehr unterschätzter Text. Also der wird auch kaum ediert und wenn überhaupt schlampig ediert. Der ist auch nach dem Zweiten Weltkrieg erst gefunden worden. Den hat er also gewissermaßen nur Freunden gezeigt. Und da geht er auf sein eigentliches Verständnis von der Wirklichkeit, in der er lebt, ein. Also die Gesellschaft interessiert ihn insofern nur, weil sie ihm sozusagen einen Arbeitsplatz verschafft, weil er da eine Institution hat. Er erfüllt auch die Bedingungen, er ist auch in Berlin, macht da bei einer Mittwochsgesellschaft mit. Er hält überall seine Vorträge. Also er entzieht sich nicht. Also er ist auf keinen Fall in irgendeiner Weise revolutionär oder kämpferisch. Sondern er fügt sich da und macht mit, aber in seinen tiefen Gedanken macht er ganz was anderes.
Und das ist in diesem Text, der später ediert worden ist unter dem Titel „Ordnung der Wirklichkeit“. Und in diesem Text, der ist 42 geschrieben und das ist jetzt einfach so, ich stelle mir das einfach so vor, 1942 wussten sie nicht was wird. Also heute wissen Sie, dass der Krieg 45 vorbei ist und die Amerikaner und Russen und so weiter, aber 42 wussten Sie das nicht. Sie wussten nicht, was da alles kaputt geht. Sie wussten nicht, wer da umkommt. Und eigentlich ist das ein Text von einem Menschen, der mit seinem Leben abschließt. Er hat nichts, worauf er sich freuen kann. Er hat die Quantenmechanik gemacht, er hat eine Familie. Die muss er jetzt natürlich auch versorgen, aber die Zukunft ist schwarz, da ist nichts. es ist sozusagen überall Gewalt, Brutalität, Krieg und jetzt versucht er sich sozusagen Rechenschaft zu geben über sein innerstes Leben und da kommt er eben auf die Idee, dass er davon träumt gewissermaßen, einen großen Gedanken zu haben, den man so in einer Phrase oder in einer Formel ausdrücken kann.
Also so wie, er spricht davon, dass die Silberseite erklingen soll. Er spricht von Beethovens Abschiedssonate, dass er so einen Dreiklang finden könnte oder so eine Melodie und davon träumt er. Also er ist vollständig da wo er sein möchte in der Kultur. Heisenberg ist ein unpolitischer Mensch, der kulturbesessen ist. Der die europäische, die deutsche Kultur für das Größte hält. An der kann er partizipieren und da geht er nicht weg. Und da können die anderen machen was sie wollen. Die können ihm noch so viele Angebote machen aus Columbia oder sonst wo her. Da geht er nicht hin. Was er tut in dieser Zeit, als die Amerikaner im Manhattan-Projekt vor allen Dingen sehr stark die Atombombe bauen, er fährt nach Budapest und hält einen Vortrag über die Farbenlehre von Goethe, ich meine nur als Kontrast.
Er hat sich ja dann auch später in der Nachkriegszeit auch gegen die weitere Entwicklung der Atomwaffennutzung ausgesprochen.
Ja er hat sich bei dem Protest der Göttinger Gelehrten, also den Carl Friedrich von Weizsäcker initiiert hat, angeschlossen. Er ist sicher nicht aufgefallen als ein politischer Kämpfer. Er ist jemand, der mitmacht, der seine Autorität einsetzt, der hohe Qualität entwickelt, aber er wollte keine Partei gründen oder so etwas. Er wird Präsident der Humboldt Gesellschaft. Das ist eine ganz andere Aufgabe. Er hält philosophische Vorträge. Er macht ja auch Vorträge. Physik und Philosophie und versucht diese neue Wissenschaft zu vermitteln. Also das ist seine eigentliche Aufgabe. Natürlich er erfüllt seine Pflicht, aber das kennen Sie doch auch, es gibt bestimmte Sachen, die erfüllen Sie, aber die haben eigentlich nichts zu tun mit Ihnen. Die machen Sie einfach, weil Sie dran sind. Da müssen Sie jetzt da hinfahren, müssen Ihr Auto da hinfahren, das interessiert Sie doch gar nicht, ob das Auto da steht oder nicht. Geht aber nicht anders. Bestimmte Sachen gehen halt nicht anders. Aber engagiert ist er nicht. Innen ist das nicht, sein Innenleben ist ein ganz anderes und das hält er schön bedeckt.
Aber er drückt das aus in „Ordnung der Wirklichkeit“. Ich würde so gerne haben, dass irgendwelche Philologen oder Philosophen diese Texte mal genauer analysieren oder auch Psychologen, welche Melancholie da drin steckt. Wie die Melancholie verarbeitet wird. Also ich sage jetzt mal als allgemeinen Vorwurf an die deutsche Wissenschaftslandschaft. Jedes Komma, das Thomas Mann im Zweiten Weltkrieg geschrieben hat, hat 20 Diplomarbeiten. Oder jeder Absatz, den er geschrieben hat, über die Nachkriegssituaion. Aber Heisenberg schreibt ein 100seitiges Manuskript. Heisenberg der Große, ein 100seitiges Manuskript, wo er sein ganzes inneres Leiden an diesem Land, an dieser Gesellschaft, an dieser Zeit darstellt und die Leute ignorieren das, das finde ich eine Blamage unserer Kultur.
Ist also noch überhaupt nicht aufgearbeitet worden?
Überhaupt nicht aufgearbeitet. Und die Edition ist eine Katastrophe. Also die ist von Freunden gemacht worden, aber das sind keine Editoren. Da braucht man Philologen, die das edieren. Da stehen Sätze drin, oder Noten sind da sogar drin, ohne dass angegeben ist, welche das sind, also müssen Sie nachschlagen. Also wenn Sie einen guten Text von Heisenberg lesen wollen, dann wollen Sie doch nicht Noten nachschlagen.
Aber was erklärt denn dieses Desinteresse?
Deutschland hat ein allgemeines Desinteresse an den Personen, die Wissenschaft machen. Also das kann man schon in der Leibniz-Zeit sehen, da haben die Leute über Franzosen, die damals gelebt haben, Biografien geschriebene, über Italiener wurde geschrieben, wie die gelernt und was die gelebt haben, Biografien geschrieben. Aber nicht über Leibniz. Auf die Idee ist gar keiner gekommen. Als Newton zum Beispiel starb, war der König da, war der Bischof da. 10.000 Leute sind zu Westminster Chappell gekommen. Als Leibniz starb hat man ihn beerdigt Punkt. Das ist der Unterscheid zwischen Deutschland und England, zwischen Deutschland und Europa. Wir feiern Heroen, also Fußballspieler, Linksverteidiger, die an der Wade gezwickt werden, aber wir feiern nicht Geistesheroen. Einstein ist einen Ausnahme, aber das hat schwierigere Gründe. Also das ist übrigens mein Vorteil meines Tuns, da so wenige Leute sich für die Biografien von großen Wissenschaftlern interessieren, kann ich die alle schreiben. Aber das ist natürlich keine Lösung.
Sondern was man braucht, wäre wirklich eine Diskussion über die großen deutschen Wissenschaftler, Planck, Born, Einstein, Heisenberg, Schrödinger und so weiter. Überlegen Sie mal, von Max Born, dem großen Max Born, ist die einzige Biografie von einer Amerikanerin geschrieben. Das ist für unser Land eine Kulturschande und wir haben ein ganzes Max-Planck-Institut für Wissenschaftsgeschichte, die nicht auf die Idee kommen, sowas zu schreiben. Die sind mit irgendwelchen Sachen beschäftigt, aber nicht mit der Biografie von großen Wissenschaftlern. Vielleicht ist das ja wichtiger, was die machen, kann ich nicht so beurteilen. Aber ich finde, um an die Öffentlichkeit zu kommen, kann man über Biografien arbeiten.
Ja gut, über Albert Einstein ist dort eine ganze Menge gemacht worden. Ist auch ein deutscher Wissenschaftler.
Ja Herr Renn schreibt da unentwegt. Aber Einstein. ist natürlich banal. Da schreiben 100 Leute in der ganzen Welt drüber und einer davon sitzt in Deutschland, hat er Glück gehabt. Was wir gerne hätten ist, dass 100 Leute über Max Born schreiben und 10 davon sitzen in Deutschland.
Aber wie erklären Sie sich denn das? Was fehlt denn sozusagen dann hier in der Wahrnehmung der Gesellschaft gegenüber dem wissenschaftlichen Bereich, dass das so eine Missachtung, Ignoranz, wie auch immer man das jetzt verstärken möchte, dass es das gibt? Ist das ein Misstrauen?
Ja nein Misstrauen nicht. Ich glaube, dass wir einfach denken, das gehört nicht zur Kultur. Also es gibt diesen schönen Satz von einem Engländer über die zwei Kulturen. Der sagt dann, also in Cambridge, aber er nennt das, die Leute kennen alle Shakespeares Sonette, aber nicht den zweiten Hauptsatz der Thermodynamik. Aber in dieser Formulierung steckt das Dilemma. Bei der künstlerischen Leistung kommt die Person mit, bei der wissenschaftlichen Leistung nicht. Wir haben so das Gefühl, dass Wissenschaft gemacht wird von Institutionen, Akademien, Universitäten und irgendwas. Aber der Künstler, das ist die Person und die Persönlichkeit, der Liebende, der Küssende, der Schmerzhabende, der Leidenschaftliche. Physiker sind nicht leidenschaftlich und haben keinen Schmerz, sie sind einfach Institutsmitglieder oder Beamte, die lassen wir einfach unter ferner liefen. Und die Grundhaltung ist ja die, man sagt, wenn in der Wissenschaft eine Entdeckung von einem nicht gemacht worden ist von einem Doktor A, dann wird sie morgen von Doktor B gemacht.
Aber wenn in der Kunst der Dichter D heute nicht die Zeile geschrieben hat, dann kann der Dichter E die morgen nicht schreiben, sondern das ist ein kreativer, einzelner, schöpferischer Akt. Wissenschaft ist nur ein Entdecken. Entdecken so wie ein Schnitzel unterm Salatblatt oder sonst irgendwas. Entdecken kann jeder, aber kreativ sein kann niemand. Und meine Behauptung ist, die eigentliche kreative Leistung ist die Wissenschaft. Und das Beispiel haben wir erwähnt, das ist Heisenberg. Einstein ist kreativ, Born ist kreativ, Schrödinger ist kreativ, Heisenberg ist kreativ. Nur die Kreativität kommt nicht so als Sonate rüber, sondern die muss man dann schildern und ausführbar machen. Aber dazu müssten sie ja jetzt die Vermittler haben. Also die Vermittler müssten die Kreativität entfalten. Und da kommt die nächste These von mir, ich glaube, wir haben immer noch das Gefühl, dass das Treiben von Wissenschaft schwierig ist, aber das Vermitteln von Wissenschaft einfach. Sozusagen nebenbei. Und ich persönlich glaube, es ist umgekehrt. Das Treiben von Wissenschaft ist einfach, wir gehen einfach nur ins Institut und machen systematisch Experimente. Das Vermitteln von Wissenschaft ist schwierig, weil Sie Fantasie brauchen. Fantasie, hat Einstein gesagt, ist wichtiger als das Wissen.
Das heißt das ist letzten Endes, man könnte das jetzt auch umdrehen und sagen, okay also die Wissenschaft verkauft sich nicht gut genug, sie ist nicht in der Lage, ihr schöpferisches Potenzial auch korrekt zu vermitteln und ein Gefühl für die kreativen Potenziale,die dort sind, und auch die Einflüsse, die es letztlich natürlich auch auf die Gesellschaft hat, es gibt natürlich die messbaren und greifbaren Einflüsse, schlicht alle Dinge, mit denen wir uns täglich umgeben im Wesentlichen, aber sozusagen es wird nicht gewürdigt und wird es vielleicht auch deshalb nicht gewürdigt, weil es nicht sich selbst richtig darstellt? Weil es sich selbst nicht richtig kommuniziert?
Ja das könnte man sagen. Also es ist so, die Vermittlung der Wissenschaft wird immer noch so betrieben, dass einem jemand erklärt, wie etwas funktioniert, nur mit einfachen Worten. Da sind zwei Schwierigkeiten drin. Erstens geht dann manchmal der eigentliche Gag verloren und dann fragen Sie sich, was Sie da eigentlich erklärt haben. Also der Niels Bohr hat immer gesagt, wenn Sie einen Parallelschwung einfach erklären ist es ein Stemmbogen, und den wollte keiner wissen. Also wundern Sie sich manchmal drüber. Wenn Sie aber jetzt den Parallelschwung verstehen wollen, dann müssen Sie ihn sozusagen zeigen, irgendwie anders empfinden und dafür hat Heisenberg auch eine schöne Formel gefunden. Es kommt in der Wissenschaft nicht darauf an, dass man sie so vermittelt, dass sie mit dem Kopf verstanden wird, sondern so dass sie mit dem Herzen verstanden wir und das macht man nicht. Also Sie müssen sozusagen das Erlebnis der Wissenschaft sehen und das geht über die Personen. Und das einzelne kreative Element, was dabei eine Rolle spielt. Also wenn sie wie gesagt nochmal den Leuten erklären, wie die Relativitätstheorie aussieht und die Lorentz-Transformation anschreiben und irgendwas von E=mc2 murmeln.
Dann ist das zwar alles ganz nett, aber die eigentliche Essenz, die Einstein erlebt hatte, als er merkte, dass diese Raum-Zeit-Geometrie ganz andere ist als man sich das gedacht hat, die ist verloren gegangen. Das eigentliche Gänsehauterlebnis ist weg. Wenn Sie das Gänsehauterlebnis durch die persönliche biografische Darstellung zurückholen, verstehen Sie die Sache mit dem Herzen, dann verstehen Sie es natürlich nicht wie im Kopf. Das heißt Sie können sich nicht bei irgendeiner Universität melden und sagen, Sie sind Experte für Relativitätstheorie oder Quantentheorie, das geht nicht. Aber Sie können in der Party herumlaufen und sagen, hey ich habe Lust gehabt, an dieser Physikwelt teilzunehmen und ich habe folgendes Erlebnis dabei gehabt und ich würde das jetzt gerne schildern. Darauf warten wir.
Ja deswegen machen wir ja auch diesen Podcast hier. Da erklären wir genau auf diese Art und Weise. Was sollte man mitnehmen von Heisenbergs schaffen und wirken und seiner eigenen Rolle, wie er sich auch selbst in der Gesellschaft gesehen hat? Und vor allem was könnten Wissenschaftler oder sollten Wissenschaftler, die heute forschen und die es vielleicht in 70 Jahren dann den passenden Podcast gibt, sozusagen beherzigen?
Also jede Zeit hat natürlich ihre eigenen Probleme. Also die Frage ist immer, die man oft gestellt hat, wenn Einstein heute noch zur Welt käme, was er dann eigentlich machen würde, seine Theorie ist ja schon da. Und was würde Heisenberg eigentlich machen, seine Theorie ist ja schon da. Also insofern muss man über was anderes gucken. Aber was man bei Heisenberg lernen kann, also in meinen Augen, aber dass es auf jeden Fall lohnt, umfassend sich zu orientieren. Also Platon zu lesen, Goethe zu lesen, Beethoven zu spielen und so ein Kulturbegriff zu finden und dann in der Kultur zu spüren, was sich ändern muss, das hat er getan. Denn er hat gemerkt, damals wurde ja die abstrakte Malerei auch geschaffen. Und der Gedanke, das Aussehen der Atome aufzugeben, kommt ja sozusagen nicht aus der Willkür dieser Physiker, sondern die haben gesehen, was da passierte. Die haben doch gemerkt, dass sich da irgendwas in der Kultur ändert. Und ich glaube so einen großen Zusammenhang muss man versuchen zu finden. Und bei Heisenberg ist die andere Sache immer noch, immer offen im Gespräch sein, immer wieder Zweifel haben.
Auch immer mit den großen Leuten sich auseinandersetzen. Also er geht ja als junger Mann, nachdem er diese Theorie hat, geht er zu Einstein und spricht mit dem durch, ob Einstein das akzeptiert. Und muss sich dann die Einwände von Einstein anhören. Und dann auch den Mut haben, rauszugehen. Und die brauchen einen Ort. Also das ist jetzt eine Sache, ich argumentiere gerne historisch. Die Quantenmechanik würde es nicht geben, wenn es nicht einen Elfenbeinturm für die Wissenschaft gegeben hätte. Wir höhnen zwar heute immer, dass Elfenbeintürme furchtbar sind und abgeschafft werden gehören. Ich bin aber der völlig anderen Meinung. Ohne Elfenbeintürme gibt es keine gute Wissenschaftsentwicklung. Ich meine nicht Elfenbeintürme, dass sich da Leute verstecken und sich nicht melden bei der Gesellschaft und gewissermaßen im Stillen ihre Bomben bauen oder so was, oder still ihre Gentechnik-Experimente machen, das ist natürlich Quatsch, das ist völliger Unsinn. Was ich mit Elfenbeinturm meine, dass Leute eine Zone haben, in der sie geschützt sind vor den banalen Problemen des Alltags.
Die gab es zwei, von denen Heisenberg beiden profitiert und partizipiert hat. Das eine war das Seminar von Max Born in Göttingen. Da hat übrigens auch Max Delbrück dran teilgenommen. Dadurch weiß ich das sozusagen aus erster Hand. Und da konnte jeder seine Meinung sagen, jeder konnte irgendwas sagen, da war ein klarer Wettbewerb der Ideen. Da waren dann auch Amerikaner da, Oppenheimer war da, Norbert Wiener war da und Russen waren da, Landau war da, Gamow war da. Die haben miteinander gestritten wie noch was. Also sozusagen das internationale offene Diskutieren in einem Elfenbeinturm. Draußen Kaffee trinken, Kaffeetasse kaufen das konnten die nicht. Oder eine Wohnung mieten, das konnten die nicht. Das hat Born gemacht oder seine Assistenten. Die waren damit beschäftigt, da rumzufummeln. Und dasselbe hat Niels Bohr in Kopenhagen gemacht. Das ist das Bohr-Instiutt in Kopenhagen. Das ist im Ersten Weltkrieg gebaut worden, vor etwa 100 Jahren gegründet worden und dann wurde da, als die Quantenmechanik da war, die Leute zu Frühjahrstagungen eingeladen.
Da war kein Programm da, kein Seminar da. Da trug halt einer vor, was ihm gerade durch den Kopf ging und die hatten dann auch Humor dabei. Also zum Beispiel da Heisenberg und Pauli die Stars waren saßen die immer in der ersten Reihe und die hatten so eine Spielzeugkanone und wenn der Redner vorne Blödsinn sagte, dann haben die die Spielzeugkanone abgefeuert und da war unterbrochen und dann wurde diskutiert. Aber das sind so offene Situationen der Wissenschaft, wo die Leute für sich bleiben. Die konnten nicht erwarten, dass die rausgehen und ein anständiges Familienleben führen, das kam später. Aber solche Situationen müsste man schaffen und das müsste man belobigen, das müsset man fördern, das müsste man befürworten und dafür müsste man … und dann können Sie diesen Leuten nicht sagen, ihr müsst jetzt Meilensteine eurer Forschung angeben, in drei Jahren müssen wir wissen was da rauskommt und dann kriegt ihr das Geld nicht. Sondern die müssen offen, frei arbeiten können. Den muss man sozusagen so einen Elfenbeinturm schaffen und dann muss man die lassen. Und dann kostet das eben, und da kommt nach drei Jahren nicht eben nichts raus.
Aber die großen Institutionen haben damit gelebt. Das Advanced-Institut in Princeton, das Caltech in Kalifornien, das MIT, die haben alle damit gelebt, dass sie die Leute sozusagen im Elfenbeinturm haben sitzen lassen und nach drei Jahren kam nichts raus und dann na gut. Aber einer kriegt was raus, zwei kriegen was raus und wenn einer was rauskriegt reicht das fürs ganze Leben.
Das ist jetzt im Prinzip eine Forderung an die Gesellschaft, wie sie mit der Wissenschaft umgehen soll. Jetzt bräuchten wir noch die Forderung an die Wissenschaft, wie sie mit der Gesellschaft umgehen soll.
Also die Wissenschaft ist natürlich heute so, dass sie anwendungsorientiert gefördert wird. Und man fragt und wundert sich jetzt natürlich sofort, die muss rechtfertigen, dass sie so viel Geld ausgibt. Aber ich glaube, dass die Wissenschaft insgesamt natürlich stolz drauf sein kann, dass das was wir unsere Geschichte nennen, das ist ja die Folge der Wissenschaft. Das ist ja nicht so, dass das die Folge von irgendwelchen Gewerkschaftsbewegungen ist, die sind auch wichtig oder auch politische Parteien. Sondern was sie heute im Wesentlichen machen, Autofahren, Telefonieren, Aufnahmen machen, Podcast senden, Wärmeenergie. Also brauchen wir nicht aufzählen, alles was Sie machen hängt von so einer wissenschaftlichen Basis ab und die Wissenschaftler sollten wissen, dass sie diesen Einfluss haben und sollten dann sozusagen diesen alten römischen Satz, bedenke das Ende. Also die sollten schon wissen, in welche Richtung das geht und an welchen Stellen man zu weit gehen kann.
Und aber die Wissenschaft sollte der Öffentlichkeit danken, dass sie bezahlt wird und dann sollte sie bereit sein, das zu erzählen. Aber ich glaube, dass sie das ist. Ich kenne keinen Wissenschaftler, der nicht bereit ist, über seine Forschung zu sprechen. Er ist manchmal nicht in der Lage, darüber zu sprechen. Weil sie dann stammeln und stottern und sich nicht ausdrücken können. Also es gibt großartige Wissenschaftler, die kriegen sofort einen roten Kopf, wenn sie vor irgendeinem Publikum stehen und sich äußern müssen. Aber diese Offenheit, die ist ja ganz selbstverständlich da und die Wissenschaft sollte auch der Öffentlichkeit klar machen, das ist immer dasselbe Wort, das ich benutze, dass da eine Kultur geschaffen wird, an der wir partizipieren. Und dass diese Wissenschaft zu unserer Kultur gehört und dass man sich darüber verständigen muss. Bildung heißt ja, ein Gespräch führen. Und deshalb ist über die Wissenschaft informiert sein und sich darüber zu unterhalten das eigentliche Bildungsgebot unserer Tage.
Was ich glaube und aber das funktioniert heute auch immer noch, ist die große friedensstiftende Bewegung. Die Fähigkeit der Wissenschaft kommt dadurch durch die internationale Kooperation. In Kopenhagen waren das auch, auch in Göttingen, Amerikaner, Russen, Franzosen, Italiener, Deutsche und die wären nie auf die Idee gekommen, gegeneinander Krieg zu führen. Deshalb war ja auch eigentlich für Heisenberg völlig undenkbar, dass da irgendwo ein Atombombenprojekt war, das hatte ja einen ganz anderen Hintergrund. Und heute gibt es so was auch. Die eigentliche große friedensstiftende Institution ist das CERN in Genf. Da arbeiten 10.000 Physiker aus aller Welt. Da arbeiten Palästinenser mit Israelis, da arbeiten Muslime mit Juden und das klappt. Ich glaube, dass die Wissenschaft so etwas sein kann, wo die Menschen durch dieses große Ziel der Wahrheit gegenüber treten zu können auf einer empirisch logischen mathematischen Basis sozusagen zu friedlicheren Menschen werden. Wissenschaft ist sozusagen eigentlich friedensstiftend.
Bedenke das Ende, das bedenken wir jetzt auch. Herr Fischer vielen Dank für die Ausführungen zu Heisenberg und den damit verbundenen Fragen an die Wissenschaft und auch an die Gesellschaft. Und vielen Dank auch hier fürs Zuhören bei Forschergeist. Es geht bald wieder weiter und bis dahin tschüss und bis bald.